ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ACOSTA AGUIAR-CURRY ALLEN
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BAKER [inaudible]
BERMAN BIGELOW.
BLOOM [inaudible]
BONTA BROUGH [inaudible]
BURKE CABALLERO.
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU
CHAVEZ CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI.
KANSEN CHU COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALLY [inaudible]
DALY EGGMAN FLORA [inaudible]
FONG FRAZIER.
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON HARPER [inaudible]
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE LOW MOAN
[inaudible]
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ.
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA REYES.
REVISE RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
[inaudible]
SALAS SANTIAGO STEINORTH
STONE [inaudible]
THURMOND [inaudible]
TING VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON WEBER.
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS
PLEASE REPORT TO THE FLOOR.
WE HAVE BUDGET BIZ BUSINESS
BEFORE THE BODY TODAY PLEASE
REPORT TO THE FLOOR
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER [inaudible]
TODAY'S PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN THE REVEREND BOB OSHITA.
REVEREND OSHITA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
KATE SPADE WOULD SHOW UP ON OUR
DOORSTEP ALMOST SEASONALLY AS A
PURSE IN A BROWN AMAZON LIKE BOX.
AND ANTHONY BOURDAIN VISITED OUR
HOME FREQUENTLY.
IN HIS SHOWS PARTS UNKNOWN AND
NO RESERVATIONS.
THEIR NAMES HAD BECOME
SYNONYMOUS WITH CREATIVE
VITALITY IN THE WORLD OF FASHION
IN FOOD.
MY WIFE LOVES KATE SPADE.
AND WE RARELY MISSED AN
OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN ANTHONY
BOARD GAMES TRAVEL AND FOOD
ADVENTURES.
HE WAS REFRESHINGLY HONEST
GENUINE AND OPEN.
BUT THESE TWO ICONS OF OUR TIMES.
WADE THEIR LIVES ON A SCALE OF
THEIR OWN.
AND CHOSE TO LIVE NO MORE.
THEY WERE SO FAMILIAR TO US.
THAT WE HAVE BEEN CREEPING.
HOW MUCH MORE SO THEIR FAMILIES
AND TWO YOUNG DAUGHTERS?
IF I COULD HAVE SAID SOMETHING
TO THEM IT WOULD HAVE BEEN.
HOWEVER LONG WE MAY LIVE.
WE WILL FIND THAT LIFE IS SHORT.
NO NEED TO ENDED EARLY.
IT WILL END SOON ENOUGH.
PLEASE RECONSIDER YOUR PERMANENT
SOLUTION. TO WHAT SEEMS SO
UNBEARABLE THAT THIS MOMENT.
THESE ARE WORDS I WISHED I COULD
HAVE SHARED.
WITH MY CHILDHOOD FRIEND GUY ONO
WHO TOOK HIS OWN LIFE IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
IN AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND THREE
I MISS HIM STILL.
HE MADE ME LAUGH HE MADE ME
THINK.
HE KEPT ME REAL.
REFLECTING ON THE GRIEF I'VE
BEEN REVISITING THIS PAST WEEK.
THIS WELL KNOWN QUOTE OF MY
ANGELO HAS GROWN EVEN DEEPER IN
MEANING [inaudible]
SHE SAID.
I'VE LEARNED THAT PEOPLE WILL
FORGET WHAT YOU SAID.
PEOPLE WILL FORGET WHAT YOU DID.
BUT PEOPLE WILL NEVER FORGET HOW
YOU MADE THEM FEEL [inaudible]
NUMBER.
ONE THAT IS TRYING TO BE
REMEMBERED BUT THE GRATITUDE AND
KINDNESS WITH WHICH WE LIVE.
THANK YOU REVEREND.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISS KOREA.
PLACE YOUR RIGHT HAND OVER YOUR
HEART READY.
BEGIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
STATES OF AMERICA [inaudible]
CHOUDARY PROBABLY [inaudible]
MISSION [inaudible]
IT IS.
THERE IS A THANK YOU MAY BE
SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO TUESDAY MAY TWENTY
NINTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE SEMI
MET AT ONE PM I WILL KEVIN
MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEM OF THE
ASSEMBLY PRESIDING CHIEF QUICKIE
DOTSON WILSON AT THE DESK RAIN
CLICK HAPPY AND LUIS READING.
NOVELS CALLED ESTIMATES AFTER
CALDERON MOVES AND MISS VALLEY
SECONDS.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE OF BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY THERE ARE
NO EXCUSE.
TO ABSENCE IS TODAY
MEMBERS WE
ARE PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
IT'S CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO US
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN NAY TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO RUBIO TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY.
OUR GUESTS WILL BE SEATED AT HER
DESK [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER THE FOLLOWING BILLS
TO COMMITTEE S. B. TWO THIRTY
SEVEN HERTZBERG IN THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE S. B. SIX SIXTY
EIGHT MCGUIRE.
FROM THE REVENUE TAXATION
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
S. B. TEN FORTY FIVE WINNER FROM
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE AND THEN BACK.
TO THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT REQUEST
IS GRANTED.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SOME GUESTS WITH
US IN THE CHAMBER TODAY
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
MS RUBIO YOU HAVE A SPECIAL
GUEST WITH US TODAY YES THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
INTRODUCE TO YOU MY MY DAUGHTER
NADIA.
LOPEZ IS HERE WITH US SHE'S BEEN
SHADOWING ME FOR THE LAST THREE
DAYS AND SHE FINALLY SAID.
YOU WORK REALLY HARD MOM SO YES
THE AND IT'S A REALLY SPECIAL
SHE'S ON SUMMER BREAK AND I SHE
HELPED THROUGH THIS PROCESS AND
SHE'S BEEN A TROOPER MY FUNDS
DOWN INTO THE CALIFORNIA RIGHT
NOW BUT HE'S BEEN A TROOPER
THROUGH THIS.
SHE ENJOYS EVERY MINUTE AND SHE
SAID THAT SHE'LL BE A FUTURE
LEGISLATOR AT LEAST --
SO WE TOLD SHE'S EIGHTEEN NOW
[inaudible]
THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
WE ARE GOING TO BE TAKING A
RECESS BEFORE WE DO SO HOWEVER
WE HAVE I GUESS THAT ARRIVED IN
CHAMBER VERY QUICKLY I'D LIKE TO
MAKE SURE WE ACKNOWLEDGE.
THAT COULD CALL ON MISTER
COOPER'S MISTER COOPER IN THE
CHAMBER.
SEEING HEARING AND LET'S GO TO
MR LACKEY.
YOU HAVE GUESTS IN THE A GALLERY
I BELIEVE.
YES VERY MUCH MEMBERS.
IF I CAN GET YOU --
TO WELCOME SOME VERY VERY
HONORABLE A GROUP OF FOLKS HERE
WE HAVE PRIDE INDUSTRIES.
WHO WORKS EFFECTIVELY IN
MAXIMIZING THE TALENTS OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES SO THEY'RE ABLE TO
PERFORM AS LABOR PARTNERS IN
MULTIPLE BUSINESS CAPACITIES?
AND THEY'RE UP THERE IN THE
CORNER THERE IN THE THEY ARE
ACTUALLY LOCATED HERE AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KYLIE'S DISTRICT
WE'RE VERY PROUD TO HAVE HIM
JOIN US.
PLEASE IF YOU COULD WELCOME
THERE.
WELCOME THEM THIS AFTERNOON
THANK YOU.
AND MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER WE'RE
GOING TO BE WELCOMING GUESTS
FROM THE JAMES RUDDER MIDDLE
SCHOOL STORY MAP TEAM AS WELL AS
EDUARDO GARCIA HAS GAS.
THE FAMILY OF XIN OF CHEN WHO IS
THE COMMITTEE SECRETARY FOR
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE IF THEY'RE
NOT IN THE GALLERY THERE WILL BE
JOINING US A BIT LATER TODAY
LET'S MAKE SURE WE WELCOME ALL
OF THEM TO THE AND WITH THAT
MEMBERS.
WITH THAT MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO BE TAKING A RECESS CENTER
CALLED THE SPEAKER THERE WILL BE
A DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS.
IN THE LOUNGE ANY REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS IN THE RULES COMMITTEE
ROOM.
WE'RE THIS IS RECESSED UNDER
CALL OF THE SPEAKER WILL WE WILL
BE RESUMING [inaudible]
SESSION.
IN JUST A LITTLE BIT AFTER THE
CAUCUSES AND AFTER A BRIEF LUNCH
BREAK.
THIS IS RECESS ON A CALL
.
NEVER HEARD BACK IN SESSION
PLEASE RETURN TO THE FLOOR
.
MEMBERS PLEASE COME TO THE FLOOR.
WE HAVE LOTS OFBUDGET BUSINESS
BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY PLEASE
RETURN A
FOR MEMBERS WE ARE
[inaudible]
SECOND READING [inaudible]
CORKERY.
SENATE BILL SIX EIGHTY EIGHT
WITH AMENDMENTS ELEVEN A SEVEN
TEN EIGHTEEN WITH AMENDMENTS
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE WITH AN IMMENSE
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE TALL THOUGH
IT WITH AMENDMENTS TO FIFTEEN
WITH AMENDMENT SEVEN FORTY SIX
AT THE MOMENT BY TWENTY FIVE AT
THE MOMENT.
SENATE CONCURRENT LUCIEN ONE OF
SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS IN ABOUT
ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS TO SIXTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS TENS OF THE NIGHT
WITH AMENDMENTS NINE FOURTEEN
ELEVEN FORTY FIVE AND THIRTEEN
TWENTY THREE ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST.
TO SANTEE RE REFER THE FOLLOWING
BILLS THE COMMITTEE S. B. C..
THE FIVE WINNER FROM THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SEVEN I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER S. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE VIED ACT TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IT WAS
ERRONEOUSLY REPORTED TO SECOND
READING.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT REQUEST
THIS GRANT
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU AGAIN
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
WITHDRAW THE FOLLOWING BILLS
FROM THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND ORDER THEM TO THE
THIRD READING FILE.
ESPY'S A FORTY ONE EIGHT FORTY
EIGHT EIGHT FIFTY A FIFTY TO A
FIFTY THREE A 548-784-02840
THREE FORTY FOUR EIGHT FORTY
FIVE AND FORTY SIX A FORTY SEVEN
A FIFTY FIVE A SIXTY ONE EIGHT
SIXTY SIX AND EIGHT SEVENTY ONE
AND IS WALTER FORT PURPOSELY.
WE OBJECT TO THAT MOTION.
MS WALTER IS WITHHOLDING
UNANIMOUS CONSENT THIS IS A RULE
SUSPENSION.
MEMBERS MOVED BY MISTER CALDERON
SECOND BY MISTER BONTA ON THE
RULE SUSPENSION MEMBERS AS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
IN HIS WATER IS ASKING FOR NO
THOUGH MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
AND MISS WALDRON AND NO.
TAKES FORTY ONE ON THE RULES
SUSPENSION.
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL EYES FIFTY FOUR
KNOWS.
TWENTY TWO THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TING TO TAKE UP THE FOLLOWING
BUDGET RELATED BILLS TODAY
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF THIRD READING.
THAT AS S. B.'S 484-018-4088
FIFTY EIGHT FIFTY TWO EIGHT
FIFTY THREE A FIFTY FOUR AND
EIGHT SEVENTY AND MISS WALDRON.
WE ALSO OBJECT TO THAT MOTION
MISS WALDRON IS WITH HOLDING
UNANIMOUS CONSENT MISTER
CALDERON MOVES ON THE ROLL
SUSPENSION SECOND BY MISTER
BONTA MEMBERS THIS IS.
AGAIN A PROCEDURAL VOTE THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
AND MISS WALDRON NO MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE TO MISS WALDRON IS ASKING%
FOR KNOW THAT THIS TAKES
[inaudible]
FORTY ONE PROCEDURAL VOTE.
PROCEDURAL VOTE MEMBERS.
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN I..
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
THREE KNOWS TWENTY ONE THE RULES
ARE SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING MOVE TO
TAKE UP.
S. B..
EIGHT FORTY WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE.
PARTY MEMBERS THIS IS ON FILE
FILE EIGHTEEN FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN
SB.
EIGHT FORTY THIS IS A CONFERENCE
REPORT CORPORATION.
SENATE BILL EIGHT FORTY BY
SENATOR MITCHELL AND ACTUALLY TO
THE STATE BUDGET TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BELT.
MISTER TING YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AFTER FOUR MONTHS AND NINETY ONE
HEARINGS IN BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEES IN CONFERENCE
COMMITTEES.
I STAND BEFORE YOU A PRESENT SB
EIGHT FORTY OUR STATE BUDGET
BILL.
IT WASN'T VERY LONG AGO THAT
THERE WERE REPORTS OF OUR STATE
FALLING INTO BANKRUPTCY.
OUR STATE HAVING AN INABILITY.
HEY EVEN THE MOST BASIC BILLS.
TODAY WE STAND VERY PROUD.
THIS PARTICULAR BUDGET BECAUSE
NOT ONLY HAVE WE MADE HISTORIC
INVESTMENTS IN K. THROUGH TWELVE
EDUCATION.
MADE HISTORIC EVENTS WITHIN
HIGHER READ CSU COMMUNITY
COLLEGES YOU SEE.
BUT WE ALSO ARE INSURING THAT WE
ARE SAVING FOR A RAINY DAY WE
NOW HAVE THE HIGHEST RESERVES IN
OUR STATE'S HISTORY.
BECAUSE WE KNOW WHEN THE NEXT
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN COMES.
THAT ONE WE HAVE TO MAKE THOSE
VERY TOUGH CHOICES WERE NOT
GONNA HAVE TO GO DO CUTS FIRST.
WE CAN GO BACK INTO OUR SAVINGS
ACCOUNT AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN FUND MANY OF THOSE REVENUES
THAT HAVEN'T BEEN COMING.
BECAUSE OF OUR GREAT ECONOMY
THAT HAVE COME TODAY.
SO JUST TO GIVE YOU A COUPLE
HIGHLIGHTS OF WHAT WE ARE
PRESENTING TODAY WE ARE NOW
FUNDING ARE KEY THROUGH TWELVE
EDUCATION OUT ELEVEN THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS.
PER PUPIL THAT'S UP FROM TEN
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED JUST TWO
YEARS AGO.
WE FUNDED THE UC AND CSU SO THEY
DIDN'T HAVE.
TO REYES TUITION ON THEIR
STUDENTS THAT WAS VERY STRONG
FEEDBACK WE HEARD REALLY ALL
ACROSS THE STATE.
AND NOT ONLY THAT BUT WE'VE ALSO
INCREASED THEIR FUNDING SO THAT
THEY CAN INCREASE ENROLLMENT
PROVIDE GREATER ACCESS FOR
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION WAS A
MAJOR PRIORITY FOR US WE ARE NOW
ADDING ONE BILLION OF FEDERAL
AND STATE FUNDS OVER THE NEXT.
FOR YEARS WHICH IS GOING TO ADD
THIRTEEN THOUSAND CHILDCARE
SLOTS IN ALMOST THREE THOUSAND
PRESCHOOL FLAWS.
THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS WHICH IS
TOUCHED ALMOST EVERY CITY.
IN OUR STATE USED TO BE
PRIMARILY URBAN PROBLEM
PRIMARILY SAN FRANCISCO.
LOS ANGELES PROBLEM NOW IS NOT
UNUSUAL TO GOING TO MODESTO OR
FRESNO OR EVEN SOME MORE THE
HARDEST HIT RULE AREAS WERE
RECEIVED PEOPLE ON THE STREETS.
SO WE ARE DOING A HISTORIC
INVESTMENT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WE ARE GIVING THE
EMERGENCY MONEY FOR THIS
EMERGENCY PROBLEM SO THAT CITIES
COUNTIES COULD BUILD SHELTER.
GET PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS OUT
FAST AS POSSIBLE.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT POVERTY IS A
HUGE ISSUE IN OUR STATE WE HAVE
ONE IN FIVE PEOPLE LIVING IN
POVERTY IN ARE STATE.
AND DURING THE DOWNTURN THOSE
PROGRAMS WERE PROBABLY THE MOST
SEVERELY CUT.
AND TO THIS POINT HAVEN'T REALLY
BEEN BROUGHT BACK SO WITH TWO
MAJOR INVESTMENTS ON CAL WORKS
AS WELL AS WELL ALLOWING PEOPLE
ON SSI ACCESS INTO CAL FRESH.
WE ARE MAKING INVESTMENTS INTO
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE WHO HAVE
BEEN LEFT BEHIND GET BROUGHT
BACK INTO THE PROSPERITY THAT
THE REST OF THE STATE
[inaudible]
FEELING.
WE BILL ON LAST YEAR'S
INVESTMENT ON THE EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT.
BY EXPANDING PEOPLE AT THE
YOUNGER AGE GROUP BETWEEN
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR BUT ALSO
THE OLDEST.
FOLKS OVER SIXTY FIVE TO BECOME
PART OF THAT EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT.
WHICH IS ONE OF THE BEST WAY
THAT WE KNOW TO FIGHT POVERTY
HERE IN OUR STATE.
I'M INFRASTRUCTURE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS AN ISSUE THAT
HAS BEEN LEFT BEHIND OVER THE
LAST DECADE WILL DECADES BECAUSE
WE REALLY FRANKLY HAVEN'T.
HAD THE RESOURCES WE ARE MAKING
SURE THAT NOW THAT WE DO HAVE
MONEY THAT WE ARE PUTTING MONEY
ASIDE FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
AND OUR INTO OUR BUILDINGS IN
OUR ROADS.
LASTLY HEALTH CARE.
HEALTH CARE WAS A MAJOR ISSUE
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR BODY.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT WE KNOW O.
WE HAVE ACHIEVED FULL UNIVERSAL
ACCESS WE'VE MADE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS SINCE THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT.
GOING FROM 78% OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE INSURANCE 292% OF
CALIFORNIA'S NOW.
HAVE HEALTH INSURANCE BUT WE
WERE ABLE TO GET.
DOT HUGE A HUGE AN ISSUE ACROSS
THE FINISH LINE.
WE GOT TO TWO MAJOR WINS.
ONE IT'S TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CELEBRATE HELPFUL.
DEVELOP A PLAN.
GET US TO UNIVERSAL HEALTHCARE
TO GET US 21100% WE ALL KNOW
THAT THE LAST.
A PERCENT AGAIN ANY
POLICYHOLDERS TO GET ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE BUT WE ARE COMMITTED.
AS CALIFORNIA'S A WE DON'T WERE
MUCH BETTER AND STRONGER WE GET
EVERYBODY INSURANCE.
AND LASTLY WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE A DATABASE TO PUT
TOGETHER TO HAVE GREATER
TRANSPARENCY AND HEALTH CARE
COSTS.
HEALTHCARE COSTS ARE ONE OF THE
MOST NON TRANSPARENT COSTS WE
HAVE IN OUR ECONOMY AND WE KNOW
THAT WE CAN DO BETTER.
SO WITH THAT I PRESENT TO YOU SB
EIGHT FORTY ARE BUDGET BILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK DRIVER.
THANK YOU MISTER TANG.
MISTER OBERNOLTE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED I THINK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WOULD LIKE TO START
WITH A BIG THANK YOU. TO
EVERYONE THAT WAS INVOLVED IN
CRAFTING THIS BUDGET IN
PARTICULAR I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL
OF THE STAFF THEY ARE THE UNSUNG
HEROES OF THE BUDGET PROCESS
OVER THE LAST FIVE MONTHS.
THEY'VE INVESTED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF HOURS OF THEIR TIME
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE STAFF NOT
JUST ON THE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
BUT ARE THE STAFF ON BOTH
CAUCUSES AND ON OUR PERSONAL
STAFF ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALL OF
YOUR HARD WORK.
BUT I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
THE MEMBERS OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE AND
ALL OF THE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEES
FOR ALL OF THE WORK OVER THE
PAST FEW MONTHS.
YOU KNOW I'M REMINDED OF
SOMETHING THAT MY WIFE SAID. TO
ME JUST AFTER THE BIRTH OF OUR
SECOND CHILD.
AND I REMEMBER VIVIDLY SHE SAID
IF WOMEN REMEMBERED HOW MUCH
PAIN WAS INVOLVED IN THIS
PROCESS.
THEY WOULD NEVER VOLUNTEER TO DO
IT AGAIN.
AND I THINK THAT'S ALSO TRUE OF
THE BUDGET PROCESS AND YET YOU
SEE THE SAME PEOPLE VOLUNTEERING
THEIR TIME YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER
YEAR TO CRAFT A BUDGET SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. TO OUR CHAIR AND
EVERYONE INVOLVED.
BUT THERE'S ACTUALLY A LOT OF
SUPPORTABLE ASPECTS TO THIS
BUDGET.
I'M VERY PLEASED THAT FOR THE
FIRST TIME WE ARE FULLY FUNDING
OUR BUDGET STABILIZATION ACCOUNT.
WERE ALSO MAKING A VERY
MEANINGFUL INVESTMENT IN
EDUCATION WERE FULLY FUNDING THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
AND WE'RE INVESTING HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN OUR CAL
STATES IN OUR UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM.
HOWEVER I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE
OVERALL LEVEL OF STATE SPENDING
IN THIS BUDGET [inaudible]
THIS IS.
BY A SUBSTANTIAL MARGIN THE
LARGEST BUDGET IN CALIFORNIA
STATE HISTORY ARE GENERAL
FURTHER FUND SPENDING FOR THE
FIRST TIME IS OVER ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS.
AND THE INCREASE IN STATE
SPENDING IS PARTICULARLY
ALARMING WE HAVE INCREASE STATE
SPENDING JUST COMPARED WITH LAST
YEAR BY ELEVEN POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE RATE.
OF KING OF INCREASE OF STATE
SPENDING THAT REPRESENTS IT IS
OVER 9% OF INCREASE COMPARED
WITH LAST YEAR.
AND THIS IS IN AN ERA.
WHEN AT THE RATE OF INFLATION IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS LESS
THAN 3%?
AND WE'RE POPULATION GROWTH IN
THE STATE IS LESS THAN 1% TO TO
PUT IT ANOTHER WAY WE ARE
INCREASING STATE SPENDING BY
OVER THREE TIMES THE RATE OF
INFLATION.
THAT IS CLEARLY UNSUSTAINABLE
AND ALTHOUGH I AM A SUPPORTER OF
FUNDING OUR RESERVE ACCOUNTS.
IT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO CONCEIVE ARE
FUNDING RESERVE ACCOUNTS TO THE
POINT THAT WOULD REALLY
ADEQUATELY CUSHION OUR STATE'S
FINANCES IN THE EVENT OF AN
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN.
IF WE CONTINUE TO INCREASE STATE
SPENDING AT THE RATE THAT WE
HAVE THEM FOR THAT REASON I
ORIGINAL VOTE.
DR CHOI.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS -- I
HAVE NOT BEEN THERE INVOLVED ARE
IN THE BUDGET PROCESS SO SO I
MEAN I THOUGHT I MEAN NOT TO
REALIZE YEAH PAYING OF THE
PROCESS BUT I APPRECIATE ALL OF
THE PEOPLE.
WHO GOT INVOLVED BUT LET ME GIVE
YOU MY AND MY GENERAL IMPRESSION?
ARE OF THE IS SO BUDGET.
I WOULD BE OUR OUR OPPOSING NOT
TODAY'S SO UP BUDGET PROPOSAL.
THIS BUDGET IS OUR IT IT
RESPONSIBLY ARE INCREASES
SUPPLEMENT ON SPENDING OP BY
ELEVEN POINT JUST SIX A BILLION
DOLLARS SO OFTEN LAST YEAR.
REPRESENTING. EIGHTY NINE POINT
THE ONE PUTS AN INCREASE AS YOU
HEARD.
THIS BUDGET THAT INCREASES ON
LONG TOM AWESTRUCK DRAWN LA
SPENDING BY BILLIONS OF THE
BALANCE.
OF WHICH I OR NIAZ ADAMS SO
FUTURE GENERATIONS SAW WITH THEM
MORE BUREAUCRACY AND THE MORE
SPENDING.
IT CLAIMS THAT A SURPLUS OF A
BILLIONS.
AND YET THE YOU KNOW MORE SO THE
STATE'S UNFUNDED PENSION
LIABILITIES SUCK AND THE
HEALTHCARE COSTS ARE DESPITE
THOUGH WHAT YOU HAVE HEARD.
THAT NUMBER IN THE HUNDREDS OF A
BILLION DOLLARS.
THIS OUR LEGISLATURE HAS TO
SPEND MORE TIME DEBATING YA
PLASTIC STROLL BANDS AND THE
FORM TAXES SO DOWN NOW
ADDRESSING CALIFORNIA SO.
APPROXIMATELY ONE TRILLION
DOLLAR SIGN IN THE STATE TO AND
A MUNICIPAL UNFUNDED PENSION
LIABILITIES.
THIS IS THE ADDRESS OF THE TOPIC
THAT I A ADDRESSED THE LAST YEAR
AS WELL.
DESPITE THE PULKOVO FISCAL YEAR
RESTRAINING THIS IS SO I JUST
THOUGHT AMADOR SMOKE AND MIRRORS.
SPEND AND ATTACKS A BUDGET.
NOT FABIO SO TO ADDRESS A THE
STATE'S ALMOST A PRESSING
CHALLENGES STAR AND ARE.
COMPROMISED IS TALK AWARD LONG
TERM ABILITY TO DELIVER BASIC
SERVICES.
I STRONGLY URGE AND THE
RESPECTIVELY ASKING MY
COLLEAGUES TO JOIN ME IN
OPPOSING SP YEAH [inaudible]
EIGHT FORTY THANK YOU.
MISS WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS --
IN ADDITION TO THE ISSUES
BROUGHT FORTH BY OUR VICE CHAIR.
I AGREE THERE ARE A LOT OF GOOD
THINGS INCLUDED IN THIS BUDGET
THE FUNDING FOR THIS CSU OF THE
UC.
ARM HEALTH FUNDING FOR A LS A
SYSTEM OF CARE INFANT HEALTH
DIABETES AWARENESS OUT REACH --
THOSE THINGS ARE GREAT --
HOWEVER.
I DO QUESTION THE ACTION I'M
ASSUMING IT'S THE ADMINISTRATION
THAT ACTUALLY WOULD CHIU
IMPORTANT ITEMS.
THAT WERE SUPPORTED BY BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AND
THE SENATE.
BUDGET COMMITTEE ON HEALTH THAT
WERE PLACED IN THE BUDGET --
Y. WITH THESE ITEMS SELECTIVELY
WITHDRAWN IN THE ELEVENTH HOUR
SIGNIFICANT ITEMS WHICH IMPACT
OUR PRIORITIES AS A STATE --
FOR EXAMPLE TREATMENT NAVIGATION
FOR OPEN YOUR USERS WHICH WAS
SUPPORTED BY --
GROUPS SUCH AS THE DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE NORTH COUNTY SAN DIEGO
LGBTQ RESOURCE CENTER LOS
ANGELES LGBT CENTER --
THIS A EFFORT WOULD HAVE FUNDED
THE OFFICE OF AIDS TO RUN HARM
REDUCTION PROGRAMS THAT REDUCE
SUBSTANCE USE.
BRING HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS TO
TREATMENT.
CLEANUP SYRINGES IN OUR HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENTS ON ON OUR STREETS
AND WOULD POSITIVELY IMPACT THE
HEPATITIS A OUTBREAK THAT WE SAW
ON SAN DIEGO FOR EXAMPLE.
I THINK OF HOW WE TALK ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS HOMELESSNESS IS A
HUGE ISSUE IN OUR STATE.
OPIOID USE DISORDER HUGE ISSUE
SURRENDERS TRASH AND THE HEALTH
RISKS WE TALK ABOUT IT BUT YOU
KNOW HERE'S A TIME WE COULD HAVE
DONE SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
AT A TIME WHEN THE WE HAVE
SURPLUS REVENUES.
OTHER ITEMS CAUGHT IN THE
ELEVENTH HOUR INCLUDE HIV S. T.
D. PREVENTION EDUCATION FOR
MEDICAL PROVIDERS.
THESE ITEMS WERE SUPPORTED BY
CALIFORNIA LGBT HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES NETWORK HARM REDUCTION
COALITION LOS ANGELES SO GPT
CENTER.
PROJECT INFORM SAN FRANCISCO
AIDS FOUNDATION ETCETERA
[inaudible]
SO -- YOU
KNOW HIV DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS
ON OLDER INDIVIDUALS THAT WAS
TAKEN OUT.
AS WELL AS HEPATITIS C.
PREVENTION NO EXPLANATION I BEG
THE QUESTION OF WHY WE TALK
ABOUT HOMELESSNESS AIDS
ADDICTION YET ENOUGH FOR IT TO
FINALLY ADDRESS THESE ISSUES.
THAT IMPACT ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY SAN
FRANCISCO LA AND SAN DIEGO ARE
IN THE BUDGET THEY'RE ACTUALLY
IN THE BUDGET THEY WEREN'T.
PART OF THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
AND THEN THEY ARE REMOVED IN THE
ELEVENTH HOUR --
WITHOUT EXPLANATION SO --
AYE URCHIN THOUGH VOTE.
MISS MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I I
RISE TODAY TO URGE A NO VOTE ON
THIS BUDGET. FOR A COUPLE OF
REASONS --
THOUGH YES THERE ARE SOME GOOD
THINGS IN THIS BUDGET BUT YOU
KNOW THE WORST THING ABOUT THIS
BUDGET IS THAT IT'S BEEN RIGGED
SO THAT NO REFUND CAN EVER BE
GIVEN TO THE TAXPAYERS.
NO CHANCE OF LOWERING THE SALES
TAX RATE BY THE QUARTER PERCENT
THAT IT SHOULD BE LOWERED SHOULD
BE REACH THAT LIMIT.
THIS BUDGET HAS BEEN RIGGED SO
THAT THAT WILL NEVER HAPPEN.
AND THAT'S DISGRACEFUL.
I MEAN I DON'T.
WORRY CREATING NEW SAVINGS
ACCOUNT IN ORDER TO NOT GIVE THE
MONEY BACK TO THE TAXPAYERS IT'S
THEIR MONEY.
WE DON'T NEED TO DO THIS.
NOT TO MENTION THE FACT THAT WE
KNOW AN AWFUL LOT OF MONEY TO
COUNTIES WHO ARE STRUGGLING.
MY COUNTY IN PARTICULAR THOUGH
THERE ARE MANY.
THEY ARE STRUGGLING WE'RE GIVING
THEM NOTHING THAT'S NOT EVEN
CONTEMPLATED IN THIS BUDGET SO
WHILE.
THE MAJORITY PARTY GOES ON A
SPENDING SPREE.
BECAUSE OF THE SURPLUS THAT WE
HAVE YOU'RE GONNA TELL YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WHO CAN'T FIND A
HOME WHO CAN'T AFFORD A HOME WHO
CAN'T AFFORD THEIR RENT OR THEIR
ELECTRICITY OR THEIR WATER BILL
OR TO PHILLIP THEIR CAR.
YOU'RE GONNA TELL THEM SORRY BUT
WE HAVE A LOT OF THINGS ON OUR
WISH LIST THAT WE'RE GONNA SPEND
THE MONEY ON THIS IS RIDICULOUS
VOTE NOW.
A SHIRT MCCARTY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS SPENDING PLAN
IT'S RESPONSIBLE AND FAIR.
I'M NOT PERFECT BUT IT IS ON
SOLID AND I JUST WANT TO RESPOND
TO SOME OF THAT COULD THE
CRITICISMS I THINK THAT THIS
BUDGET.
AS OUR CHAIRMAN FROM SAN
FRANCISCO DISCUSSES FOCUSES ON
SAVING AND REALLY LEARN FROM THE
MISTAKES OF THE PAST COULD YOU
LOOK BACK. TO GOVERNOR'S AGO.
WE HAD EXTRA MONEY.
WE HAD A SURPLUS.
AND WE OVER COMMITTED OURSELVES.
WE SAID THAT MONEY BACK TO THE
TAXPAYERS WE OVER COMMITTED AN
ON GOING.
PROGRAMS AND THERE WAS A PRICE
TO PAY WE HAD TO INCREASE TAXES
ON CALIFORNIANS WE HAD TO SLASH.
EDUCATION PROGRAMS HIGHER
EDUCATION PROGRAMS HEALTH CARE
PROGRAMS IT WAS PAINFUL FOR
EVERYBODY SO WHAT WE DO HERE.
WE LEARN FROM THOSE LESSONS OF
THE SO CALLED NINE BILLION
DOLLARS OVER HALF OF IT IS SAVED.
FOR A SO CALLED RAINY DAY.
WAITING FOR THE NEXT RECESSION
BECAUSE IT WILL COME.
AND THE OTHER MONEY IS SPENT ON
RESPONSIBLE THINGS LIKE ONE TIME
INFRASTRUCTURE AND EDUCATION I
KNOW IN OUR SUBCOMMITTEE WE HAD
UNANIMOUS VOTE ON OUR SPENDING
PLAN BECAUSE WE ALL SUPPORT MORE
MONEY GOING TO OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. TO EARLY EDUCATION TO
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION TO
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS TO OUR
UC'S TO OUR CS USE.
THAT'S A PRIORITY TO DETER TO
SAY THAT IT'S IRRESPONSIBLE
SPENDING I THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY.
ARE NOT THE CASE AND THE NOTION
THAT WE'RE SPENDING THIS MONEY
ON ON GOING SPANISH JURORS LIKE
SO CALLED DRUNKEN SAILORS.
GO TALK TO THE PEOPLE ROTH WAS
FOR MORE MONEY AND HEALTH CARE
GO TALK TO PEOPLE OFFICE FOR
MORE MONEY IN EARLY EDUCATION.
GO TALK TO PEOPLE ASK US FOR
MORE MONEY.
AND OTHER SOCIAL PROGRAMS WE
COULD NOT GOING BECAUSE WE'RE
FOCUSING ON ONE TIME NEEDS AND
SAVING FO THE FUTURE IN OUR
CORE EDUCATION.
THAT EXPENSES SO IN SOME OF
THESE ACCIDENTS WILL HELP US
WITH THE NEXT DOWNTURN --
THEY CUSHION US FROM FUTURE
PAINFUL CUTS IN EDUCATION.
AND HEALTH CARE AND PRETTY THE
CUSHION US FROM POTENTIAL A
HARMFUL TAX INCREASES TO OUR
MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES AROUND
CALIFORNIA AGAIN THIS IS A
RESPONSIBLE SPENDING PLAN.
ASK YOUR ABOUT THANK YOU.
THINGS REGARDING MR FRAZIER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
COLLEAGUES ARE RISE --
TO HIGHLIGHT SOME ISSUES THAT
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT WITH THIS
BUDGET.
AS YOU ALL KNOW SAFETY OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS A HUGE
PRIORITY OF MINE SINCE MY
DAUGHTER DIED ON A CALIFORNIA
STATE HIGHWAY.
UNFORTUNATELY SINCE I'VE BEEN
HERE THE STATE'S HIGHWAYS
BECAUSE HAVE BECOME LESS SAFE.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TEN CRASHES
OF INCREASED 29%.
AND THE NUMBER OF DEATHS PER
MILE DRIVEN HAS INCREASED 27%.
THE STATISTICS FAR OUTPACED THE
STATE'S POPULATION GROWTH OF 8%.
AS WELL AS THE INCREASE HAVE
BEEN LICENSED DRIVERS AND
REGISTERED VEHICLES OF 11%.
DECLINING SAFETY OF OUR HIGHWAYS
IS DIRECTLY RELATED.
TO THIS FACT SINCE TWO THOUSAND
TEN THE NUMBER OF HIGHWAY PATROL
OFFICERS ON OUR ROADS HAS
ACTUALLY DECREASED BY 5% MATTER
OF FACT LADIES AND GENTLEMAN.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE THE HIGHWAY
PATROL WAS CUT THREE HUNDRED
POSITIONS AND NEVER RESTORE.
LET ME REITERATE THIS POINT.
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION NUMBER
OF REGISTER VEHICLES AND
LICENSED DRIVERS.
CAN YOU TO INCREASE WHILE
HIGHWAY PATROL OFFICERS HAVE
BECOME [inaudible]
FEWER.
THE RESULT OF THESE DIVERGENT
TRENDS ARE CLEAR.
MORE ACCIDENTS AND AN INCREASED
FATALITY RATE.
MORE PEOPLE ARE DYING EVERY DAY.
IT'S TIME FOR OUR STATE TO TAKE
ACTION TO REVERSE THIS TREND AND
WE PROBABLY FUND THE OFFICERS WE
NEED AND DEPEND ON TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS CAN TRAVEL SAFELY.
THIS IS WHY I HAVE ASKED FOR
MORE FUNDING FOR CHP OFFICERS IN
THIS BUDGET.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE
ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T BELIEVE
THIS IS A PRIORITY THEREFORE WE
WERE DENIED THIS REQUEST.
INSTEAD WE PRIORITIES PRIORITIZE
OTHER NEW SPENDING SUCH AS A
BUNCH OF NEW POSITIONS AT THE
AIR RESOURCE BOARD TO DO
ADMINISTRATIVE WORK AND BUILD
DATABASES.
WE'RE DEDICATING SEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
GENERAL FUND TO REDUCE THE WHAT
RISK OF WHALEN SEA TURTLE
ENTANGLEMENT.
BUT INCLUDE KNOWN NEW FUNDING TO
REDUCE THE RISK OF PEOPLE DYING
ON OUR HIGHWAYS.
AMAZINGLY WE APPROACH OF UP WERE
PROVING TWO POINT NINE MILLION
FOR PHASE [inaudible]
ONE SPACE OPTIMIZATION.
OF PROJECT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
EPA HEADQUARTERS.
MEANWHILE THE BUDGET TRANSFERS
OF EIGHTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT
TO THE GENERAL FUND.
WHICH HAVE BEEN.
SHOULD HAVE BEEN UTILIZED FOR
THE ADDITIONAL OFFICERS
DESPERATELY RICK NEEDED RIGHT
NOW.
THIS FUNDING COULD PROVIDE THE
STATE WITH FOUR HUNDRED MORE
OFFICERS.
AND BRING THE DEPARTMENT BACK TO
THE NUMBER OF OFFICERS THAT HAD.
BEFORE THE RECESSION.
I REPEAT BEFORE THE RECESSION.
INSTEAD THE MONEY'S GOING TO THE
GENERAL FUND WHERE WE EXPECT TO
HAVE A SIXTEEN BILLION DOLLAR
SURPLUS.
OUR ROADS ARE LESS SAFE AND WE
HAVE THE MEANS TO ADDRESS IT.
THE BUDGET FAILS TO DO SO.
SO IT MAKES ME QUESTION OUR
PRIORITIES WHEN WE LOOK AT THIS
DIFFICULT SITUATION.
SAVING PEOPLE'S LIVES.
PLEASE HELP ME NEXT IN THE NEXT
BUDGET CYCLE AND MAKE A
COMMITMENT.
A SAFE CALIFORNIA'S LIVES SO
THEIR FAMILIES WON'T HAVE TO
SUFFER LIKE I DID WHEN MY
DAUGHTER DIED.
MEMBERS IF YOU WISHED TO SPEAK.
PLEASE RAISE YOUR MICROPHONES
NOW.
PLEASE RAISE YOUR MAC FUNDS NOW
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK.
MISTER HARPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
WELL THERE ARE MANY THINGS I CAN
SAY GOOD ABOUT THIS BUDGET I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT UNDERSCORE
THAT I AM DISAPPOINTED THAT THIS
BUDGET FAILS TO RETURN MORE
DOLLARS TO THE HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS.
EVEN AS WE SEE THIS NINE BILLION
DOLLAR SURPLUS.
IN I WANT TO AFFIRM THE POINT
THAT WAS BROUGHT UP BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LAKE ELSINORE.
THAT WITH FUNDS IN THE STATE'S
EMERGENCY ACCOUNT TOTALING MORE
THAN 4% OF GENERAL REVENUE.
A QUARTER CENT SALES TAX SHOULD
BE TRIGGERED AUTOMATICALLY.
IS DUE TO LAWS THAT WERE
SUPPOSED TO KEEP STATE LAWMAKERS
FROM HARDING FUNDS YET GOVERNOR
BROWN LEGISLATIVE DEMOCRATS OF
DECIDE TO BE CREATIVE.
IN THEIR ACCOUNTING PRACTICES TO
CREATE NEW SAVINGS ACCOUNTS THAT
WOULD BYPASS THE EXPECTED SALES
TAX CUT AND I THINK THIS IS
WRONG NO MATTER HOW HOW ABOUT
YOU CUT IT.
ADDITIONALLY AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE YEAR THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE
WHO ARE COMPLAINING ABOUT
FEDERAL TAX REFORM THAT'S IMPACT
ON CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS.
AND I WANT TO UNDERSCORE ITS NOT
INCLUDING.
INCOME TAX RELIEF.
WE NEED A SPECIFIED THAT WHEN WE
OUT THESE KINDS OF REVENUES THAT
IT'S AND CALIFORNIANS ARE INDEED
OVER TAX.
AND ONE OF THE BEST WAYS TO
PROMOTE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
THIS STATE IS TO ALLOW
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS TO KEEP
MORE OF THEIR OWN HARDER AND
HARDER AND DOLLARS.
AND THAT'S WHY A LOT ONE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IN FUTURE
BUDGETS ARE THAT WE INCLUDE MERE
AYE.
INCOME TAX REFORM THAT ALLOWS
FOR AN STATE TAX REDUCTION I
THINK YOU VERY MUCH A MUCH
SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK ON
THE ITEM PLEASE REFER
MICROPHONES NOW MR THURMAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB EIGHT FORTY ONE OF MY
FAVORITE SAYINGS IS THE ONE THAT
GOES -- YOU
SHOW YOUR VALUE.
I WOULD YOU PUT YOUR BUDGET.
A AND CERTAINLY THERE ARE THINGS
THAT WE COULD ADVOCATE FOR THAT
THERE SHOULD BE MORE OF THIS IN
MORE OF THAT --
BUT ON BALANCE THIS IS IN FACT.
A BUDGET THAT STRIKES A GOOD
BALANCE.
WE HAVE LISTENED TO THE VOTERS
WHO'VE ASKED US. TO BE PREPARED
FOR RAINY DAY WE HAVE ENHANCED
AND MAXIMIZE SAVINGS A FOR
FUTURE DOWNTURNS THIS BUDGET
PROVIDES MORE. FOR IMPORTANT
INSTITUTIONS THAT HELP
CALIFORNIANS LIKE A COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE UC'S ARE YOU SEE
ISSUES WE PUT MORE MONEY INTO K.
TWELVE EDUCATION.
AND WE PUT MORE MONEY INTO EARLY
EDUCATION AND WE PROVIDE DOLLARS
TO SUPPORT.
LOW INCOME WORKING FAMILIES TO
THE EITC AND OTHER PROGRAMS TO
HELP.
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE STRUGGLING.
AND WE'VE HEARD.
FROM OUR CITIES THAT THEY NEED
HELP.
THEY NEED HELP TO ADDRESS.
HOMELESS CHALLENGE THAT
CONTINUES TO GROW AND INTENSIFY
EVERY SINGLE DAY COLLEAGUES THIS
CALL IT WHAT IT IS A VOTE
AGAINST THIS BUDGET.
YOU CAN IS REALLY A VOTE AGAINST
ALL OF THESE THINGS CALIFORNIA'S
HAVE ASKED US.
A PORT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU VOTE
YES IT SHOW YOUR VALUE.
BY WHAT WE PUT INTO OUR BUDGET.
THANK YOU MISS THURMOND.
MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK.
MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS MEMBERS THIS
BUDGET BILL TOUCHES ON EVERY
PART OF CALIFORNIA THAT WE LIVE.
AND ON THE THINGS THAT WE WOULD
LOVE TO IMPROVE.
WE LOVE OUR OCEANS ARE MOUNTAINS
ARE STANDING ENVIRONMENT.
AND THIS BUDGET HELPS US TO
PROTECT WHAT'S THERE.
AND WORKS TO MAKE IT ACCESSIBLE
TO EVERYONE.
WE ALSO LOVE THE AMAZINGLY
DIVERSE COMMUNITY THAT IS
CALIFORNIA.
BUT WE REALIZE THAT NOT EVERY
NEIGHBOR IS HOUSED.
NOT EVERY CHILD HAS SOLID
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES NOT
EVERY PERSON WHO IS SICK IS
GETTING THE CARE THAT SHE OR HE
NEEDS.
THIS BUDGET IS A PLAN FOR
BUILDING SOMETHING GREAT.
IT MOVES US TOWARDS THE
CALIFORNIA.
OF OUR DREAMS.
CALIFORNIA'S NIGHT AT UTOPIA.
WE'RE WORKING ON IT.
WANT TO THANK THE BUDGET CHAIR
FOR HIS HARD WORK ALL OF THE
BUDGET SOBS AND ASK FOR A NIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER WITH
THAT MISTER TAINE YOU MAY CLOSE.
LET ME JUST CLOSE BY ECHOING ARE
SPEAKER IN ARE VICE CHAIRS
COMMENTS IN JUST AGAIN.
THANK THE SUB CHAIRS WHO CHAIRED
THE HOURS OF HEARINGS.
AS WELL AS OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE
STAFF AND ALL THE MEMBER STAFFS
FOR EVERYONE WHO SERVES ON
BUDGET COMMITTEE IT IS --
A HUGE AMOUNT OF WORK IN A HUGE
AMOUNT OF TIME --
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM RICHMOND
TALKED ABOUT THE BUDGET IS A
REFLECTION OF OUR SNOW TELL YOU
WHAT IS NUMBER.
ONE IN OUR BUDGET AND THAT'S
EDUCATION.
EDUCATION GOT THE MOST AMOUNT OF
MONEY WHETHER IT'S K. THROUGH
TWELVE EDUCATION OR HIGHER
EDUCATION.
IT'S IN EVERY SINGLE ONE OF OUR
DISTRICTS IT'S THE MOST CRITICAL
ISSUE TO OUR FAMILIES AND TO OUR
CHILDREN.
AS HOW WE PROTECT OUR FUTURE
INITIAL THE CALIFORNIA CONTINUES.
TO BE THE PROSPEROUS STATE THAT
IT IS AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I DON'T
WANT SB.
EIGHT FORTY THANK YOU MISS TANK
THEN WITHOUT CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE NEW DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
.
MR TANG MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE UP [inaudible]
A. B..
EIGHTEEN THIRTY ONE
MEMBERS WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE WE'RE TAKING UP SB.
EIGHT FORTY ONE S. B..
EIGHT FORTY ONE WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE.
MISS SH JUROR TANG YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU ARE MAINLY FORTY ONE
AS OUR ANNUAL DEFICIENT THING
DEL [inaudible]
ASSERTING CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL EIGHT FORTY ONE BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AND ACTUALLY AT
THE STATE BUDGET MAKING
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BILL.
MR TANG ON S. B. A FORTY ONE
THANK YOU SPEAKER FTA FORTY ONE
IS OUR ANNUAL DEFICIENCY BILL.
THE BILL APPROPRIATE DEPARTMENT
EIGHT HUNDRED AND NINETY BILLION
DOLLARS TO COVER COSTS THAT WERE
UNEXPECTED --
MOST THESE COSTS WERE IN MEDI
CAL EIGHT HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR
MILLION. FORTY FIVE MILLION OF
THOSE COSTS WERE IN UNEXPECTED
CORRECTIONS WITHOUT AYE A
THRIVING.
THANK YOU MISTER TANG.
MR OBERNOLTE THANK MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS TO BE CLEAR THIS
IS THE ONLY TRAILER BILL THAT
WE'RE CONSIDERING TODAY THAT
AFFECTS THE CURRENT YEAR BUDGET.
NOT OF THE NEXT YEAR BUDGET
WHICH STARTS JULY FIRST IT IS
VERY DIFFICULT IN FACT ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO EXACTLY ESTIMATE
WHAT REVENUES ARE EXPENDITURES
ARE GOING TO BE IN A GIVEN YEAR.
SO IT'S NECESSARY TO GO BACK AND
TRUE UP THE FIGURES WITH THE
ESTIMATES THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
DOES.
OF THESE EXPENDITURES TO BE
CLEAR HEARD BY THE STATE AND
THEREFORE THIS IS SUPPORTABLE
AYE URGENT AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
CHIANG MAI BECAUSE YOU WISH.
COR CLUB THE ROLL-ON PARA VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE BUT I
SEVENTY SIX KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS NEXT WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE THIS IS S. B.. EIGHT
FOUR EIGHT THE CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL EIGHT FORTY EIGHT BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AND ACTUALLY TO
TRANSPORTATION MAKING A
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET.
MISTER TECH.
THANK YOU FOR SPEAKER S. B.
EIGHT FOUR EIGHT IS OUR
TRANSPORTATION TRAILER BILL
ABOUT THE BILL LIMITS CALTRANS
ADMINISTRATIVE CHARGES FOR WORK
IT DOES FOR THE TWENTY FOUR SELF
HELP COUNTIES.
IT ALSO POSTS AN ADDITIONAL ONE
DOLLAR TRANSACTION FEE TO RECOUP
THE COST.
DMV SYSTEM IMPROVEMENTS FOR FIVE
YEARS.
BUT THAT I ASCRIBE.
MR OBERNOLTE YOUR RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
BILL ALLOWS CITIES AND COUNTIES
TO BORROW AGAINST THE REVENUE.
FROM THE GAS TAX INCREASE THAT
WAS PASSED BY THIS LEGISLATURE
LAST YEAR.
GIVEN THE FACT THAT IT IS HIGHLY
LIKELY THAT VOTERS WILL BE
CONSIDERING A REPEAL OF THIS GAS
TAX INCREASE ON THE BALLOT THIS
NOVEMBER.
IT SEEMS VERY UNWISE TO ALLOW
LOCAL AGENCIES TO BORROW AGAINST
REVENUE WHICH MAY NOT BE THERE.
ANOTHER THING THAT THIS TRAILER
BILL DOES IS IT IMPOSES AN
ADDITIONAL ONE DOLLAR PER
TRANSACTION TAX.
ON PRIVATE COMPANIES THAT
CONTRACT WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES TO PROCESS
VEHICLE REGISTRATION AND TITLE
CHANGES.
THESE PRIVATE COMPANIES SEEK TO
PROCESS THESE TRANSACTIONS
OUTSIDE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLE FIELD OFFICES AND
THEREFORE THEY REDUCE LINES AND
WAIT TIMES WITHIN THOSE FIELD
OFFICES WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT
WE AS A STATE HAVE BEEN
STRUGGLING WITH.
RONALD REAGAN ONCE SAID THAT IF
YOU WANT MORE OF SOMETHING YOU
SHOULD SUBSIDIZE IT AND IF YOU
WANT LESS OF SOMETHING YOU
SHOULD TAXES.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT MORE OF
SO WE SHOULD BE SUBSIDIZING IT
WE SHOULD CERTAINLY NOT BE
TAXING IT.
ARGENEAU VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE.
MISTER LACKEY YOUR RECKON.
YES OF SPEAKER MEMBERS REAL
QUICKLY I WOULD URGE A NO VOTE
[inaudible]
SIMPLY BECAUSE THE REMARKS BY
OUR COLLEAGUE GO [inaudible]
FROM OAKLEY.
INDICATED THE THE ABSENCE OF ANY
SUPPORT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL.
AND ESPECIALLY WITH THE NEW
NORMAL WITH ALL THESE NEW FIRES.
THAT TO AND THEY CONTINUALLY
HAVE TO SUPPORT.
AND IT PUTS A A SIGNIFICANT.
STRAIN ON EACH ONE OF THE
COMMANDS. TO BE ABLE TO DO THE
SAFETY ENFORCEMENT THAT'S ALSO.
PART OF THEIR RESPONSIBILITY SO
UNFORTUNATELY IT DOES NOT
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE VERY
CRITICAL SERVICE.
ASPECT IN TRANSPORTATION SO I
WOULD URGE A NOBLE.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY MISS
MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU FOR THE MUSICAL
INTERLUDE --
SO I AM GOING TO URGE A NO VOTE
ON THIS BILL FOR A COUPLE OF
REASONS NUMBER ONE THIS
LEGISLATURE IS ENCOURAGING
[inaudible]
LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES TO PUT
THINGS ON THE CREDIT CARD.
WHY ARE WE DOING NOW WHY ARE WE
ENCOURAGING OUR CITIES TO PUT
THINGS ON THE CREDIT CARD TO GO
INTO DEBT TO BORROW AGAINST
FUTURE FUNDING? FOR FINDING THAT
MAY NOT EXIST.
IF THERE'S REPEAL OF THE GAS TAX
AND UP ON THE BALLOT SO THEN
WHAT THEN WHAT ARE CITY SPACE TO
DO THEN THEY'RE STUCK HOLDING
THE BAG.
BECAUSE THEY BORROWED AGAINST
THEIR FUTURE ANOTHER FUNDS
AREN'T THERE. TO COVER THOSE
COSTS SECONDLY [inaudible]
ARE I KNOW THIS IS HOW THESE
TRAILER BILLS WORK BUT WHY DO WE
HAVE EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS GOING.
FOR A BICYCLE CORRIDOR POD
PROJECT IN LOS ANGELES.
THAT IS RIDICULOUS AND INSULTING
BY URGING A VOTE.
MISTER HARPER YOUR RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I IS MORE MORE CALIFORNIANS ARE
DEMANDING REPEAL THE GAS TAX I
CONTINUE TO CALL FOR INSTEAD.
THAT NINE POINT ALTERNATIVE PLAN
FOR FUNDING OUR TRANSPORTATION
NEEDS I THINK WE NEED TO GET ON
THE BALL AND UNDERSTAND WHAT
CALIFORNIANS ARE ASKING FOR
WHICH IS NOT ADDITIONAL TAXES.
BUT MORE WISELY SPENDING THE
MONEY WE ALREADY HAVE AND MAKING
OUR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE PRIORITY WITHOUT
EXISTING FUNDING.
WE NEED TO LOOK FOR A DIFFERENT
PATH TOWARDS OUR TRANSPORTATION
BUDGETING AYE AND I URGE YOU
KNOW VOTE ON THIS BILL.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
RETAIN YOU MAY BECAUSE WE WISH.
WITH THAT.
CLERK WILL DRAW.
ON THEM AS HER DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE
ICE BEFORE KNOWS TWENTY FOUR
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE HAVE AMENDMENTS.
ON THIS NEXT ITEM.
AMENDMENTS TO S. B. EIGHT FIFTY
THAT CORPORATE GREED.
SENATE BILL EIGHT FIFTY WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TALLY.
MISTER DALLI ARE THE METHODS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE. TO OFFER THESE
AMENDMENTS THAT INVALIDATED
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION'S
MANDATE.
THAT MOST RESIDENTIAL HOMES.
THERE ARE TO BE BUILT WAS SOLAR.
WE SHOULD KNOW THAT WE
OVERPRODUCED SOLAR IN THE STATE
ALREADY.
AND BY ADDING MORE --
SOLAR IS GOING TO DRIVE THE
PRICE UP OF HOUSING --
AT ABOUT TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER HOME.
AS THE WALLSTREET JOURNAL
ESTIMATED WOULD BE ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND SEVEN DOLLARS A
MONTH. FOR THE FOR AN ANNUAL A
FOR A NORMAL MORTGAGE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS --
WE LET IT A BUREAUCRACY OR
BUREAUCRATS THAT AREN'T ELECTED
TO THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION.
MAKE THIS --
BECOME LAW AND WE'RE GONNA
FORCED A HOMEOWNERS TO PUT SOLAR
ON THEIR HOMES WERE ALREADY OVER
PRODUCING SOLAR IN CALIFORNIA.
SO IONS THAT YOU ADOPT THESE
MINUTES AND WE COME BACK AND
THAT WE ARE.
REMOVE IT AND WE START LOOKING
AT THINGS THAT REALLY ARE GOING
TO HELP THE ENVIRONMENT WE
SHOULD BE PRODUCING.
GREEN ENERGY WHEN THE SUN IS NOT
SHINING BECAUSE WHEN THE SUN IS
SHINING WERE ACTUALLY PAYING
OTHER STATES. TO TAKE OUR ENERGY
AND WE'RE OVERDUE SECRETS OR
SUBSIDIZE THEM THANK YOU
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED NAY GALLAGHER MOVED
TO LEYVA AMENDMENTS.
IT'S CALLED ARMS MOVING TO LAY
THOSE AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE
SECOND BY MISTER BONTA.
MEMBERS IS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE
MAJORITY PRESENT AND VOTING.
CLARK LOVE IN THE ROLE.
CALDERON TASK WHEN I MR DOWN THE
KNOW WHICH CALDERON IS ASKING
FOR AYE VOTE MISTER DALLI IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE THIS IS. TO
LAY THE MEMBERS ON THE TABLE.
MAJORITY PRESENT AND VOTING
[inaudible]
CLERK.
WILL CLOSE THE ROLL EYES FIFTY
TWO KNOWS TWENTY ONE THE
AMENDMENTS ARE LAID ON THE TABLE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP
THE BILL AND CHIEF.
S. B. EIGHT FIFTY CLERK WILL
READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHT FIFTY BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY THE HOUSING
MAKING A PREPARATION THEREFORE
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET.
MISTER TING YOU MAKE AN OPEN.
THANK IT WAS SPEAKER S. B. A
FIFTY AS OUR HOUSING TRAILER
BILL THE MOST SIGNIFICANT.
PROGRAM WITH THAT IT IS THE
HOMELESS EMERGENCY AID PROGRAM
WHICH IS BEING ESTABLISH.
DISTRIBUTES OVER FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS INTO OUR CITIES
IN OUR COUNTIES AND REALLY
HELPING THEM FIGHT HOMELESSNESS
ON OUR STREETS TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION THAT WAS.
DISTRIBUTED BY FORMULA BY THE
GOVERNOR A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DIRECTLY ALLOCATED TO
CITIES WITH A POPULATION OVER
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND
LAST WE A HUNDRED MILLION. TO BE
DISTRIBUTED BASED ON THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN HOMELESS POINT IN
COUNT --
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I DON'T.
THE IMAGE TING MISTER OBERNOLTE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I DON'T THINK A SINGLE PERSON IN
THIS CHAMBER WOULD DISPUTE.
A STATEMENT THAT HOMELESSNESS IS
ONE OF THE MOST CRITICAL ISSUES
FACING THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IN FACT WE RT SPELLBOUND A
STUNNING AMOUNT OF MONEY.
FIGHTING THIS PROGRAM BUT BEFORE
WE SPEND MORE MONEY.
ON THIS ISSUE I THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE FOR US TO TAKE.
SOMETIME AND DO SOME
INTROSPECTION ABOUT THE
EFFECTIVENESS.
OF WHAT WE ARE DOING.
BECAUSE DESPITE ALL OF THE MONEY
THAT WE SPEND ON THIS PROBLEM.
THE ISSUE CONTINUES TO WORSEN IN
FACT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA NOW
HAS THE WORST HOMELESSNESS.
OF ANY STATE IN THE COUNTRY 25%.
OF THE HOMELESS POPULATION OF
THE ENTIRE UNITED STATES.
IS RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO I THINK WE NEED TO CONSIDER.
THE APPROACH THAT WE ARE TAKING
TO FIGHTING THIS PROBLEM ANY
PARTICULAR CONSIDER WHETHER OR
NOT WE ARE TREATING THE SYMPTOM
OF HOMELESSNESS.
OR THE ROOT CAUSES OF
HOMELESSNESS.
I'M REMINDED OF A SITUATION
WHERE A PATIENT GOES TO SEE A
DOCTOR HE SAYS DOCTOR I HAVE A
HEADACHE.
AND THE DOCTOR DIAGNOSES BRAIN
CANCER.
SO YOU WOULD EXPECT THE DIAG THE
DOCTOR TO TREAT THE CANCER YOU
WOULD NOT EXPECT THE DOCTOR TO
TELL THE PATIENT TAKE TWO
ASPIRIN THAT'LL FIX THE PROBLEM.
AND I FEEL.
THAT THAT'S THE SITUATION WITH
HOMELESSNESS WITH THIS BILL WE
ARE TREATING THE SYMPTOM OF
HOMELESSNESS THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE HOMES.
WERE WE NEED TO PAY MORE
ATTENTION TO THE ROOT CAUSES OF
HOMELESSNESS.
THESE ROOT CAUSES ARE VERY
DIFFICULT TO SOLVE ADMITTEDLY
BUT THEY ARE WELL UNDERSTOOD
THEIR THINGS LIKE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE [inaudible]
JOBLESSNESS [inaudible]
MENTAL ILLNESS.
AGING ISSUES AND LACK OF ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE AND LET US NOT
FORGET THE HIGH COST OF HOUSING
IN CALIFORNIA.
SO BEFORE WE MOVE FORWARD BY
TREATING THE THE SYMPTOM OF THE
PROBLEM I THINK WE SHOULD
PAPER PUT MORE ATTENTION TO
TREATING THOSE ROOT CAUSES ALSO
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THE WAY THAT
THE FUNDING IN THIS BILL IS
DISTRIBUTED.
HALF OF THE FIVE HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS IN BLOCK GRANTS IS
DISTRIBUTED OF THIS TRAILER BILL.
ARE USING A SYSTEM CALLED THE
POINT IN TIME COUNT AND THAT'S A
SYSTEM THAT HAS BEEN SHOWN TO
DISPROPORTIONATELY BENEFIT.
THE LARGEST CITIES IN OUR STATE
AT THE EXPENSE OF THE SMALLER
CITIES AND COUNTIES IN OUR STATE
SUCH AS THE ONES THAT I
REPRESENT.
I CAN TELL YOU WE ARE SEEING
HOMELESSNESS IN PARTS OF OUR
STATE WHERE WE HAVE NEVER SEEN
IT BEFORE INCLUDING MANY OF THE
PARTS IN OUR DISTRICT.
THIS IS A PROBLEM THAT WE NEED
TO SOLVE STATEWIDE NOT JUST IN
THE LARGEST CITIES ARGENEAU VOTE.
MISS QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AND ESPECIALLY TO MY
COLLEAGUES FROM ORANGE COUNTY.
THIS MEASURE S. B. EIGHT FIFTY
AND A. B. EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN IS IN
FACT CENTRAL TO THE HOMELESS
CHALLENGE WE ARE CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING THROUGHOUT ALL OF
ORANGE COUNTY AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IT IS NOT A SECRET THAT BOTH THE
COUNTY AND CITIES IN MY DISTRICT
ARE BEING CHALLENGED IN FEDERAL
COURT TO STEP UP AND JOINED.
THE EFFORT TO REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS ARAFAT.
THIS LAST WEEKEND I WALKED THE
RAILROAD TRACKS FROM FULLERTON
TO ANAHEIM WHAT THE FEDERAL
JUDGE JUDGE CARTER TO SEE THEM
CAN'T MINUTES THAT WE WOULD ALL
BE SHOCKED TO SEE NOT ONLY IN
ORANGE COUNTY BUT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I'VE SEEN THESE ENCAMPMENTS
ACROSS THE RIVER BED IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND THIS IS NOT THE
CALIFORNIA THAT WE CAN BE PROUD
OF THIS IS THE CALIFORNIA THAT
WE MUST ACT TOGETHER AS
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS. TO
FIGHT THIS ISSUE SO ALTHOUGH
THERE IS NOT ONE SOLUTION THERE
ARE MANY FROM MENTAL HEALTH TO
HEALTH CARE TO EDUCATION TO
PERMANENT HOUSING AND EMERGENCY
HOUSING SO I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
TO SUPPORT THOSE.
THAT ARE FACING HOMELESSNESS.
THIS MELENDEZ YOUR RECOMMENDS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN IN THE PAST TWENTY
YEARS THIS STATE HAD SPENT
NEARLY ONE TRILLION DOLLARS ON
FIGHTING POVERTY INFIGHTING
HOMELESSNESS YET WHAT HAS
HAPPENED.
IT HAS INCREASED OKAY ONE POINT
TWO BILLION LOCAL BOND ISSUE IN
LA FOR HOMELESSNESS.
THE CITY COUNCIL SAID NO THANK
YOU.
KAZAN WANTED IN THEIR BACKYARD
THE MONEY HAS BEEN SPENT SAN
FRANCISCO SPENDS TO TURN SIXTY
MILLION ANNUALLY ON HOMELESSNESS.
TELL ME HOUSE THE HOMELESS
POPULATION DECREASED IN SAN
FRANCISCO OR INCREASED IF YOU'VE
BEEN THERE RECENTLY YOU WOULD
KNOW THAT IT AS INCREASED AS IT
HAS ACROSS THIS STATE THAT ARE
THE ANSWER.
IS NOT ALWAYS THROW MORE MONEY
AT IT BECAUSE THIS SOLUTION
[inaudible]
SEEMS LIKE THE INTENT IS TO JUST
GET THE HOMELESS POPULATION OUT
OF SIGHT OF PEOPLE SO THAT THEY
FORGET ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE A HOMELESS PROBLEM.
AND THERE IS MORE THAN ONE
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM THE IT
BUT THE ONLY SOLUTION IS
BRINGING FORWARD.
IS MONEY.
TEMPORARY HOUSING TEMPERATE WHAT
ABOUT ALL THE THINGS THAT CAUSE
PEOPLE TO BE HOMELESS IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
WHAT ABOUT THE HIGH COST OF
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA WHAT ABOUT
THE HIGH COST OF ELECTRICITY OF
WATER OF GAS OF RENTING A HOME
OF BUYING A HOME?
EVERYTHING IN CALIFORNIA IS
EXPENSIVE AND HAS GOTTEN MORE
EXPENSIVE.
THAT'S THE REASON WHY WE HAVE
MORE PEOPLE WHO ARE HOMELESS BUT
THERE'S NO SOLUTION ON THIS
FLOOR TO TO DO ANYTHING ABOUT
THOSE ISSUES IT'S JUST LET'S
JUST TAKE MORE TAXPAYER MONEY.
AND TRY TO PUT A BAND AID OVER
THIS PROBLEM.
PUTTING MORE MONEY INTO IT
DOESN'T SOLVE THE PROBLEM
ENTIRELY SO I'M ASKING YOU AT
WHAT POINT WILL THIS LEGISLATURE
TAKES SERIOUSLY.
THE EPIDEMIC THAT IS TAKING
PLACE IN THE STATE REGARDING THE
HOMELESS THE NEED MORE THAN JUST
TEMPORARY HOUSING THEY NEED MORE
THAN JUST A BUDGET TRAILER BILL
THAT MAKES IT LOOK LIKE.
WE'RE DOING SOMETHING WHEN IN
FACT WE'RE NOT MOVING THE BALL
FORWARD I URGE A NO VOTE.
I THINK THIS ONE IS.
SEE NO DISH NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM MISTER TING
YOU MAY CLOSE THINKING THAT
SPEAKER --
THANK YOU FOR THE VERY
APPROPRIATE DEBATE ON THIS ISSUE
OF HOMELESSNESS IT VERY MUCH IS
A CRISIS AND ALL OF OUR CITIES
AND COUNTIES TO PUT DOWN THE
STATE.
THAT THE FUNDING IS PRIMARILY
BASED ON THE POPLATION OF
HOMELESSNESS SO WELL WITH DUE
RESPECT FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BIG BEAR EVERY SINGLE PART OF
THE STATE.
DOES GET MONEY IN THIS FORMULA
FUNDING HOWEVER THE COUNTIES
WITH THE LARGEST POPULATION OF
HOMELESS IS DID GET MORE AND
THAT'S REALLY HOW IT WAS BASED
IN MIXED TEAMS BECAUSE SENSE.
YOU'RE TRYING TO PUT MORE FUNDS
THE PROBLEM THIS YEAR TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE MONEY IS
SPREAD ALL ACROSS THE STATE.
WITH DO RESPECT TO ALL THE OTHER
ISSUES THAT WERE DISCUSSED WE WE
COMPLETELY AGREE WE ACTUALLY
NEED TO BUILD MORE HOUSING WE
LAST YEAR.
OF THIS LEGISLATURE ACTED IN
HISTORIC FASHION ON A LARGE
SCALE HOUSING PACKAGE WE KNOW
THAT THAT WAS JUST THE BEGINNING.
NOT AND WE NEED TO KEEP MAKING
SURE THAT WE BUILD MORE HOUSING
MORE PERMANENT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AS WELL AS MORE MARKET
RATE HOUSING THAT ACTUALLY IS.
PART OF THE SOLUTION MENTAL
HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH IS
ABSOLUTELY A KEY COMPONENT WE
HAVE --
PARTS IN TRAILER BILLS AS WELL
AS IN THE BUDGET WHERE WE ARE
GRAPPLING WITH MENTAL HEALTH
IT'S AN ISSUE THAT WE DEFTLY
DON'T PAY ENOUGH ATTENTION TO
AND WE SHOULD PAY MORE ATTENTION.
TO WITH SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
VERY ACUTELY AWARE IS AN ISSUE
ON DRUG ABUSE AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE THE ISSUE THAT WE ARE
DEALING WITH IN THE BUDGET WILL
BE AT LYFT UP APPROPRIATED MORE
MONEY IN THIS BUDGET ABSOLUTELY.
BUT AGAIN WE WANTED TO BE
FISCALLY PRUDENT MIXTURE WE SET
ASIDE RESERVES MAKE SURE WE WERE --
INVESTING IN OUR FUTURE SO I
THINK IT IS OUGHT HAD ONE POINT.
FOR GONNA PEOPLE ARGUE THAT
WE'RE SPENDING TOO MUCH AND YET
WE'RE NOT SPENDING ENOUGH IN
THESE OTHER AREAS.
AGAIN I THINK WHAT WE DID IS WE
HAVE A VERY BALANCED APPROACH TO
THIS BUDGET WE INVESTED IN OUR
BIGGEST PRIORITIES WAS AROUND
EDUCATION. TO THE CENTERPIECE
BUT WE ALSO WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DEALT WITH THIS
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS WHICH HAS
BEEN SPREAD ALL ACROSS OUR STATE
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISS TANG AND WITH
THAT CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
VOTE.
S. R. TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TIED ABOUT AYE SIXTY
THREE KNOWS FIFTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION.
S. B.. EIGHT FORTY ONE S. B.
EIGHT FORTY EIGHT AND S. B..
EIGHT FIFTY WILL BE IMMEDIATELY
TRANSMITTED TO THE SENATE.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT S. B.. EIGHT
FIFTY TWO OUT.
REFERENCE TO FILE THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHT FIFTY TO BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AND ACTUALLY THE
STATE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT MAKING
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET.
MISTER TANG YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER S. B. EIGHT
FIVE TWO RATIFIES THE MEMORANDUM
OF UNDERSTANDING AGREED.
TO BY THE STATE AND BARGAINING
UNIT SIX CORRECTIONS.
REPRESENTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION.
THEN WILL YOU WOULD BE IN EFFECT
FOR ONE YEAR.
WITHOUT I RESPECT FOR US RIGHT.
THEY WERE SITTING MISTER
OBERNOLTE ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I HAVE A DEEP
RESPECT FOR THE WORK THAT OUR
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS DO IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT I HAVE
SOME CONCERNS.
WITH THIS MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING THIS IS A SINGLE
YEAR M. O. U..
THAT IMPLEMENTS A 5% GENERAL
SALARY INCREASE.
AND THIS IS IN A YEAR WEIGH ON
INFLATION IS UNDER 3% OR
INCREASING GENERAL SALARIES FOR
THIS BARGAINING UNIT BY ALMOST
TWICE THE RATE OF INFLATION.
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS THE
HIGHEST COST PER INCARCERATED
PRISONER OF ANY STATE IN THE
COUNTRY THIS SUMMER YOU WILL
EXACERBATE THAT SITUATION.
I HAVE A FURTHER CONCERN WITH
THE MO YOU.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HUMAN RESOURCES IS REQUIRED BY
STATE LAW TO SUBMIT A REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE.
AT LEAST SIX MONTHS BEFORE THE
EXPIRATION OF THE SYMBOL YOU.
AND THAT REPORT IS SUPPOSED TO
DETAIL.
DIFFERENCES AND COMPARISONS
BETWEEN THE SALARIES AND
COMPENSATION OF MEMBERS OF THIS
BARGAINING UNIT.
WITH SIMILAR EMPLOYEES AND OTHER
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AND PRIVATE
INDUSTRY.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS NEVER
RECEIVED THAT REPORT.
AM WITHOUT THE CONTEXT THAT THAT
REPORT WOULD PROVIDE I FIND IT
VERY DIFFICULT TO APPROVE AN
INCREASE IN SALARY OF THIS SIZE
ORIGINAL VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE SINGH
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
YOU'RE TAKING A CLOSE.
THINK MY SPEAKER THIS --
BARGAIN YOU'D AGREEMENT WAS VERY
MUCH A COMMENSURATE OTHER
PARKING UNIT AGREEMENTS LIKE
BELIEVE GIVEN HOW HARD AND
ECHOING MY COLLEAGUE FROM --
BIG BEAR'S COMMENTS GIVEN HARD
THE CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
WORK UP AND DOWN OUR STATE I
BELIEVE THIS --
AND WILL YOU DESERVES OUR
CONSIDERATION BUT THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IT.
THING WHICH TING WITH VACLAV
GLOBAL ROLL-ON VOTE.
THE SAD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS SO.
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE IN TIME BUT I
SEVENTY KNOWS.
FIVE THAT MEASURE PASSES AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE.
MEMBERS THIS IS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE.
S. B.. EIGHT FIFTY THREE
COOPERATE.
SENATE BILL EIGHT FIFTY THREE BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AND EXPLAIN A
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET.
MISTER TING YOU MAKE AN OPEN.
I THINK IT SPEAKER S. B. EIGHT
FIVE THREE IS OUR DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TRAILER BILL PROVIDES
FOR ADDITIONAL PROTECTIONS.
CLIENTS RIGHTS ACCESS
TRANSPARENCY EMPOWERMENT RELATED
TO VARIOUS ASPECTS OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SYSTEM.
PERFORMS LANGUAGE RELATED TO THE
ADMISSION TO A DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER IT OR DEPARTMENT OPERATES
A FACILITY. TO INSTEAD REFERRED
TO AN ACUTE CRISIS HOME.
AND LASTLY REQUIRES EACH
REGIONAL CENTER TO INCLUDE ON
ITS INTERNET WEBSITE ANY
PROCEDURE AND ASSESSMENT TOOL
USED BY THE REGIONAL CENTER.
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I DON'T SB.
EIGHT FIVE THREE THANK YOU
MISTER TANK.
MISTER OBERNOLTE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES THESE ARE
GOOD PROGRAMS IN PARTICULAR THE
BEST BUDDIES PROGRAM IS A
PROGRAM THAT HELPS.
THOUSANDS OF DISABLED
CALIFORNIANS LIVES BETTER LIVES
AND MAXIMIZING FEDERAL FUNDING
FOR THE SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAM WILL HELP.
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOP DISABILITIES LIVE MORE
INDEPENDENTLY OF THESE ARE GREAT
PROGRAMS AYE RIGID AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE
MISTER FRAZIER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I ALONG WITH THE INTO
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES COMMUNITY.
ARE DISAPPOINTED ONCE AGAIN THAT
THE CRUMBS THAT FALL OFF THE
TABLE ARE LEFT TO THOSE WHO MOST
NEED IT.
PROGRAMS PROMISED ME RESTORED
FOLLOWING THE RECESSION
INCLUDING SOCIAL A RECREATION IN
CAMP.
ARE LEFT OUT OF THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET DESPITE BEING APPROVED BY
BOTH HOUSES.
MEMBERS SOCIAL RECREATION CAMPUS
FOR THOSE AUTISTIC CHILDREN WHO
HAVE TO HAVE CONSISTENCY IN
THEIR LIVES.
WHEN SCHOOL ENDS IN SUMMER
SCHOOL THERE IS A GAP OF THREE
TO FOUR WEEKS THAT ABSOLUTELY?
OF BEHAVIOR SPIKES THAT BEING
HOW ARE HAPPENING --
IT'S IS TO A TRAVESTY WHAT'S
DONE TO THE PARENTS TO HAVE TO
LEAVE WORK TO BE ABLE TO PROTECT
THESE CHILDREN.
OF FROM FROM NOT HAVING OBSERVE.
OF THE EMPLOYMENT RATE.
OF REMAINS BELOW 20% FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH ID DE AND YET
SUB MINIMUM WAGES YET WE CAN'T
FUND COMMUNITY BASED VOCATIONAL
SERVICES. FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
TO EXPAND EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES WILL GO A LONG WAY
TO SUSTAIN INDIVIDUALS WHO SEEK
EMPLOYMENT EMPLOYMENT BUT
LEAVING GET THAT EITHER.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE OUR
PRIORITIES ARE BUT IT STEPHANIE
NOT WITH THIS COMMUNITY.
I WILL VOTE TODAY FOR THIS
BUDGET BECAUSE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IS GOING TO
SERVICES IN.
IN HIGH COST AREAS OF FOREST
MANAGEMENT EVEN THOUGH IT HAS
LIT A LITTLE CHANCE OF BEING
SPENT.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING ON
MAKING SIGNIFICANT STRIDES FOR
NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET THAT WE HAVE
TO MAKE.
AND CONCERTED EFFORT FOR THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
BUT LOOK FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO
NEXT YEAR.
THANK YOU MISS FRAZIER MR MATHIS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
BUT YOU MISTER SPEAKER AYE TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
HOWEVER.
I WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
WE MISSED KEY OPPORTUNITIES THAT
WOULD HAVE GREATLY HEALTH ARE
DISABLED COMMUNITY.
ERROR NUMBER OF PROPOSALS THAT
WERE DENIED DURING CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE DESPITE RECEIVING
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN BOTH THE
SENATE.
AND ASSEMBLY SUBCOMMITTEES. FOR
EXAMPLE WATER WE DELAYING
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE GOVERNOR'S
MANDATORY FOR LOW DAYS.
INSTEAD OF REJECTING THEM OUT
RIGHT.
IN ADDITION WHY DOES THIS
LEGISLATURE NOT RESTORE THE
SOCIAL CAMP PROGRAMS WHICH WOULD
GREATLY BENEFIT.
OUR DISABLED COMMUNITY.
I DO NOT AGREE THAT THIS
LEGISLATION.
HAS SOME IMPORTANT PROJECTS FOR
DISABLED COMMUNITY [inaudible]
BUT MEMBERS.
THERE A LOT MORE THAT MUST BE
DONE.
BUT I ASK THAT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD NEXT YEAR WE WE GET THIS
RIGHT.
BECAUSE EVERY YEAR WE TALK ABOUT
HOW MUCH WE CARE ABOUT OUR
DISABLED COMMUNITIES WE TALK
ABOUT DOING THE RIGHT THING.
IN IT EVERY YEAR I'VE BEEN HERE
WE WE HAVE GREAT PROPOSALS THAT
GO FORWARD AND THEN WHEN IT
COMES TO THIS POINT THE BUDGET.
THEY GET CUT.
SO WE HAVE TO FIX THAT.
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE HAVE A RECORD
BUDGET BEFORE US.
WE HAVEN'T CAUGHT UP TO WHAT THE
BUDGET CUTS WERE.
AND WE NEED TO GET THERE.
SO WHAT YOU TO THINK ABOUT THAT
IS YOU GO HOME AFTER VOTE YES ON
THIS WE HAVE TO SUPPORT.
COMMUNITY BUT WE HAVE TO
ACTUALLY DO THE RIGHT THING.
AND FULLY FUNDED INSTEAD OF JUST
TALK ABOUT IT.
ALL THE BAY HAVING CEASED ON THE
ITEM MISTER TAKING A CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I HOUSE
WITH EVERY BUDGET WE'VE DONE
MANY MANY GREAT THINGS BUT
THEY'RE ALWAYS FOR POLLS THAT WE
JUST DON'T HAVE --
FOR MOVING FORWARD THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT THIS IS A
COMMUNITY THAT DESERVES OUR
RESPECT AND OUR FUTURE
COMMITMENT AND OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE
TO KEEP.
WORKING TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
GET THE FUNDING THAT THEY
DESERVE WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A BUT WITHOUT THE CLERK
WILL OPEN ROLL-ON MEMBERSHIP OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS HAVE THE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WELL.
CLOSE WRONG TIE THAT I SEVENTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES AND WITHOUT OBJECTION.
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE.
MEMBERS WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE THIS IS S. B. EIGHT FIFTY
FOUR CORPORATION.
SENATE BILL EIGHT FIFTY FOUR BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC RESOURCES MAKING A
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATE
TO THE BUDGET [inaudible]
MR TANK.
I THINK MUCH SPEAKER S. B. EIGHT
FIVE FOR IS OUR RESOURCES ON THE
BUS TRAILER BILL MAKING VARIOUS
STATUTORY CHANGES.
RELATING TO RESOURCES AND ENERGY
SOME OF THOSE ARE AUTHORIZING
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD TO
IMPOSE FEES ON APPLICANTS
SEEKING FOR CERTIFICATION.
OF AFTERMARKET PARTS THAT
EXTENDS REVENUE GENERATION
PROGRAMS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS AND RECREATION.
AUTHORIZES THE CALIFORNIA INDIAN
HERITAGE CENTER PROJECT IN YOLO
COUNTY.
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE TO CONTRACT WITH AN
INDEPENDENT ENTITY. TO UNDERGO A
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING EXERCISE
OR CREATES THE HEALTHY STORES
REFRIGERATION GRANT PROGRAM TO
ROARED GRANTS TO QUALIFY
ENTITIES. FOR THE PURCHASE OF
ENERGY EFFICIENT.
REFRIGERATION UNITS BY SMALL
BUSINESS.
IT CHANGES THE NAME OF THE
CALIFORNIA P. UC'S OFFICE OF
RATE PAYER ADVOCATE PUBLIC.
ADVOCATES OFFICE OF THE CPUC.
WITHOUT AYE AYE STRIVE.
THEY WERE STAYING WITH HER
OBERNOLTE THANK RESEARCHER
MEMBERS THIS TRAILER BILL
IMPLEMENTS A WIDE VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT POLICY CHANGES RELATED
TO NATURAL RESOURCES.
NOTICE THAT I SAID POLICY
CHANGES THESE ARE NOT BUDGETARY
ITEMS THEY HAVE NO PLACE ANY
BUDGET TRAILER BILL.
WILL GIVE YOU A COUPLE OF
CONCRETE EXAMPLES THERE WERE
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT THE
CHAIR JUST MENTION THE WILD AND
SCENIC RECREATIONAL RIVER
DESIGNATION.
SP FIFTY CLEAN UP AND THE
PLASTIC MARKET DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM REAUTHORIZATION THESE
ARE SUBSIDES TENTATIVE POLICY
ISSUES THEY SHOULD BE INTRODUCED
IN POLICY COMMITTEE ARGUED IN
POLICY COMMITTEE.
AND PASSED THROUGH THE REGULAR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND NOT
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS
ARGENEAU VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE
SEEING NO.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
STIR TANG YOU MAY CLOSE WHO WISH
[inaudible]
WITHOUT.
COR CLUB.
MEMBERS.
IT IS OUT OF ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY VOTE I
FIFTY THREE KNOWS TWENTY TWO
THAT MEASURE PASSES AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE AND MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTION.
THANK YOU FIRST SPEAKER PURSUANT
TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER TO THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO
COMMITTEE S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
SEVEN PORTANTINO. FOR THE
PURPOSE COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT REQUEST
IS GRANTED.
MAYBE MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULES SIXTY
THREE IN SEVENTY SEVEN TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TEAM TO TAKE UP
THE FOLLOWING BUDGET RELATED
BILLS WITHOUT REFERENCE FILE.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE
AND SENATE AMENDMENTS THOSE ARE
A BEES EIGHTEEN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN TWENTY FOUR EIGHTEEN
THIRTY ONE EIGHTEEN TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SIX EIGHTEEN
THIRTY IN.
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FOUR I MISS
WALDRON HOW WE OPPOSE THAT
MOTION MISS WALDRON IS
WITHHOLDING UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
CALDERON IS MOVING THE RULE
SUSPENSION A SECOND BY MISTER
BONTA.
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE CARPOOL UP IN THE ROLE.
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
MS WALDRON IS ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING
FOR AN I. THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE MISS WALDRON IS.
ASKING FOR NO VOTE.
TAKES [inaudible]
FORTY ONE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL EYES FOR THE FORD
KNOWS.
TWENTY FIVE THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE UP WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE [inaudible]
A. B. [inaudible] EIGHTEEN
SEVENTEEN CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN SEVENTEEN
BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
ACTUALLY THE STATE GOVERNMENT
MAKING APPROPRIATE AND THEREFORE
TO TAKE IT BACK TO ME LEGALLY TO
THE BUDGET [inaudible]
MISTER TING.
THINK WHAT SPEAKER A. B.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTEEN AS A GENERAL
GOVERNMENT TRAILER BILL.
FIGHTS FINANCING FOR PHASE THREE
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCIENCE CENTER
CREATES A SMALL BUSINESS.
DEVELOPMENT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
EXPANSION PROGRAM.
ESTABLISHES THE STATE'S
SUPPLEMENTATION FOR COUNTY
ASSESSORS PROGRAM IN RENAMES THE
CALIFORNIA SECURE CHOICE
RETIREMENT SAVINGS A CAL SAVINGS
TRUST ACT. TO KELSEY RICH
RETIREMENT SAVINGS PROGRAM.
WITHOUT I ASKED DRIVERS.
THEY WERE STAYING MISTER
OBERNOLTE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THIS BILL CONTAINS A
WIDE VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
APPROPRIATIONS THAT ARE LARGELY
SUPPORTABLE FACT OF THE BILL.
IS OVER ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
PAGES LONG SO IF YOU HAVE READ
IT ALL I SALUTE YOU.
BY A PARTICULAR NOTE IS AS THE
SPEAKER THE ARCHER MENTIONED THE
SMALL BUSINESS TECHNICAL
EDUCATION EXPANSION ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WHICH WILL
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. TO
JOB CREATORS SUCH A SMALL
BUSINESSES ENTREPRENEURS AND THE
SELF EMPLOYED THIS IS A VERY
SUPPORTABLE PROGRAM AYE URGENT
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE SEEN
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLE.
I'M VOTERS OUT TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AND ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE AND HOW ABOUT I
SEVENTY SIX KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS THIS IS A BE EIGHTEEN
TWENTY FOUR WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN TWENTY
FOUR BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND ACTUALLY THE STATE
GOVERNMENT MAKING PREPARATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT ILLEGAL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET
[inaudible]
MISTER TECH.
I THINK IT WOULD SPEAKER A. B.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY FOURTH ANOTHER
GENERAL GOVERNMENT TRAILER BILL
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS PARENTS MASTER
PLAN FOR THE STATE'S. EIGHT
VETERANS HOMES BY DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY NINETEEN
INTO UPDATE THEM EVERY FIVE
YEARS.
ALLOWS PACIFIC REIMBURSABLE
ACTIVITIES FOR COUNTIES FOR THE
REPLACEMENT OF THEIR VOTING
SYSTEMS ARE PROHIBITS ISSUING IF
MINOR FIX THE TICKET TO CARSON
OF MODIFIED MUFFLERS TO
INCREASED NOISE.
OR EXHAUST SYSTEMS THAT MAKE
UNUSUAL OR EXCESSIVE NOISE AND
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA VICTIMS
COMPENSATION BOARD TO CONSIDER
COMPENSATION FOR VICTIMS.
OF THE EAST AREA RAPIST ALSO
KNOWN AS THE GOLDEN STATE KILLER
WITH THAT I ASKED FOR A THEY
WERE STAYING MISTER OBERNOLTE OR
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
BILL --
ALLOWS THE STATE TO FULLY
REIMBURSED COUNTIES FOR THE
PURCHASE OF VOTING SYSTEMS I
FEEL THAT ONE OF THE MOST
FUNDAMENTAL JOBS THAT WE DO IN
GOVERNMENT IS TO ENSURE THE
CONTINUED FUNCTION OF OUR
DEMOCRACY.
THIS BILL APPROPRIATES A
RELATIVELY MODEST AMOUNT OF
MONEY IN FURTHERANCE OF THAT
GOAL IS WORTHY OF SUPPORT AYE
URGENT AYE VOTE.
IT'S QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. FOR ELEVEN YEARS IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES AND EIGHTIES
THE GOLDEN STATE KILLER STALKED
ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND ONE OF THE
LONGEST AND MOST VICIOUS CRIME
SPREES IN THE U. S..
HISTORY BURGLARIZING MORE THAN A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY HOMES RATE IN
MORE THAN FORTY PEOPLE IN
MURDERING ANOTHER. TWELVE FOR US
IN ORANGE COUNTY WE REMEMBER THE
FEAR THE NEWS ACCOUNTS OF THE
GRUESOME KILLINGS AND YES THE
TEARFUL FACES A FAMILIES AND
LOVED ONES LEFT TO COPE WITH
THEIR LOSS.
AS AYE VOTE TODAY FOR THIS BILL
I WILL BE VOTING FOR THE VICTIMS
AND ORANGE COUNTY WHICH WAS ON
TUESDAY AUG AUGUST. NINETEEN
NINETEEN EIGHTY KEITH AND
PATRICE HARRINGTON FROM DANA
POINT.
THAT FRIDAY FEBRUARY SIXTH
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE MANUELA
WOULDN'T COME FROM IRVINE.
IN ORANGE IN SUNDAY MAY FOURTH
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX JANELLE
CREWS FROM IRVINE IN ORANGE YET
JUST AS IMPORTANTLY I WILL BE
VOTING FOR THE LOVED ONES WHO
ARE NOW RELIVING THE PAINS IN
THE FEARS AND THE TRAUMA.
THROUGH THE NEW ACCOUNTS OF THE
REPORTED KILLER AND HIS VICTIMS
MEMBERS THIS MEASURE IS AOF
RELIEF FOR GRIEVING FAMILY
PROVIDES FAN FINANCIAL HELP FOR
COUNSELING AND OTHER MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND FOR THOSE
FAMILIES I URGE YOU TO JOIN WITH
ME.
TOO VOTE YES ON THIS ITEM.
THANK YOU IS QUIRK SILVA MISTER
COOLEY HERE RECOGNIZE.
COLLEAGUES OUR RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THE SAME SUPPORT FOR VICTIMS
OF THE GOLDEN STATE KILLER.
MY WIFE AND I MOVED INTO RANCHO
CORDOVA FROM THE BAY AREA.
IN APRIL OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN I BEGAN MY CAREER ON APRIL
ELEVENTH OF THAT DAY IN THIS
BUILDING.
FOUND MYSELF LIVING IN A HOME
ONE SH.
A JUST OPERATE TO FEEL WITHIN A
MILE.
AS WE MOVED HERE OF WHERE THINGS
ARE HAPPENING THEN RANCHO
CORDOVA.
SO I CERTAINLY REMEMBER AS A
YOUNG HUSBAND IN THE SECOND YEAR
OF OUR MARRIAGE LIVING
ARRANGEMENT OVER WITH THESE
RAPES AND MURDEROUS ACTIVITIES
NEARBY.
NEVER REALIZE HOW GRATEFUL I BE
FOR THE FOR THE GERMAN SHEPHERD
DO WE HAVE IN OUR BACKYARD.
OF MY HOME WAS UP AGAINST A
DRAINAGE CANAL.
WHICH WOULD HAVE AFFORDED IN ONE
ACCESS AND DAD DIED.
BUT I HAD A NICE LARGE GERMAN
SHEPHERD THERE [inaudible]
SO ARE [inaudible]
COURSE.
PURSES ACROSS THE EIGHT THE
SUMMITEERS WERE AFFECTED BY THIS.
A DISCONNECTED BODY BUT I
CERTAINLY REMEMBERED AS HAVING
LIVED IN THE AREA WITH BY.
YOUNG BRIDE.
I THINK IT WAS COOLEY SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE
SHOOTING MAKE CLOTHES IF YOU
WISH.
JUST RESPECT FRANCE PRIVATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
INSIDE A VITAL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF AND I SEVENTY
SEVEN DOES ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
OUR CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS THIS IS AB EIGHTEEN
TWENTY FIVE WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN TWENTY
FIVE BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND ACCURATE EDUCATION FINANCE
BIG PREPARATION THERE FOR THE
TICKET BUT THE MEDIA LETHAL
RELATE TO THE BUDGET
[inaudible]
MISTER TING.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
EIGHTEEN A. B. EIGHTEEN TWENTY
FIVE CREATES A NEW PROCESS FOR
CERTIFYING THE PROP NINETY EIGHT
MINIMUM.
GUARANTEE BEGINNING WITH THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
FISCAL YEAR.
SPECIFIES ARE AT THE STATE OVER
APPROPRIATES THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE IN PRIOR YEARS THE
EXCESS AMOUNT NOT TO EXCEED 1%.
WILL BE CERTIFIED TO THEIR PROP
NINETY EIGHT SCHEDULE AND CAN BE
USED TO MEET THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE OF FUTURE YEARS.
IT ALSO SPECIFIES THAT ANY
SETTLE UP FUNDED.
O. FUNDING O. TO SCHOOL SHOULD
BE ALLOCATE ON A PER STUDENT
BASIS LESSEN ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
SCHEDULES ADOPTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE I WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FIVE THEY WERE STAYING IN WITH
THAT CLERK WILL BE THE ROLE.
MY APOLOGIES MISTER OBERNOLTE
STRUCTURAL.
MISTER OBERNOLTE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR A CURRENT
STATE LAW REQUIRES THAT ANNUALLY
THE DIRECTOR OF FINANCE THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION AND THE CHANCELLOR.
OF THE OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM.
ANNUALLY CERTIFY THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT GUARANTEE CALCULATION AND
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO THAT.
WITHIN NINE MONTHS AFTER THE END
OF EVERY FISCAL YEAR YOU KNOW
WHEN THE LAST TIME THAT ACTUALLY
OCCURRED WAS.
WAS IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT TEN
YEARS AGO SO THIS IS CLEARLY A
PROCESS THAT NEEDS REFORM THIS
TRAILER BILL WILL ACCOMPLISH
THAT REFORM AND AT THE SAME TIME
ADD MORE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT.
AND MORE TRANSPARENCY THE
PROCESS IT IS VERY SUPPORTABLE
AYE URGENT AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
STINGING MY CLOTHES WHO WISH.
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW I THAT I
SEVENTY NINE KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
OUR CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS A BE.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SIX WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN TWENTY
SIX BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND ACTUALLY THE STATE BUILDING
MAKING PREPARATION THEREFORE TO
TAKE AFFECTED ME LEGAL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET.
MISTER TING EMAIL.
THEY COMMIT SPEAKER A. B.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SIX IS OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE TRAILER BILL.
THIS BILL FOR THE POOR
GOVERNANCE IN FINANCING MODEL
FOR REBUILDING THE CAPITAL ANNEX.
THE PROJECT WILL INCLUDE A
BUILDING SWINGS SPACE ON ó
STREET BETWEEN TENTH AND
ELEVENTH.
FELL BENCH WOULD BECOME A NEW
STATE OFFICE BUILDING.
THE PROJECT WILL BE MANAGED BY
THE PUBLIC WORKS COURT WITH
INPUT FROM THE LEGISLATURE.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIGHT.
TEAMS TING MISTER OBERNOLTE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I THINK
EVERYONE IN THIS CHAMBER WOULD
AGREE THAT THE CAPITAL AND ACTS
IS IN DIRE NEED.
OF RECONSTRUCTION OR REPLACEMENT
HOWEVER I FIND IT VERY TROUBLING
THAT THIS TRAILER BILL EXAMS THE
ENTIRE CAPITAL ANNEX PROJECT.
FROM THE PROVISIONS OF THE STATE
CONTRACT CODE INCLUDING THE
PROVISIONS FOR COMPETITIVE
BIDDING.
I FIND IT EXTREMELY HYPOCRITICAL.
THAT WE TELL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THAT THEY MUST COMPLY WITH THE
STATE CONTRACTED CODE FOR THEIR
REQUIREMENTS.
BUT THEN WE EXEMPT OURSELVES
FROM OUR OWN LARGEST PROJECT
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE FACT THAT
THE STATE ANNEX RECONSTRUCTION
WILL BE ONE OF THE MOST LARGE OR
ONE LARGEST.
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS IN
THE ENTIRE STATE WHEN IT'S DONE
I URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE
MISTER ACOSTA.
I THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I IN ADDITION TO WHAT'S ALREADY
BEEN MENTIONED REGARDING THE
CONTRACTING PROVISIONS OF THAT I
FIND EGREGIOUS IN THIS
PARTICULAR BILL HAVING COME FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT BEING DICTATED
TO BY THIS CHAMBER IN THIS HOUSE --
HOW WE SHOULD?
OPERATE.
I HAVE SOME OF THE POINTS
REGARDING.
THIS PARTICULAR BILL --
THE ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN NEW BONDS THIS BILL
AUTHORIZED REPRESENT FRANKLY A
GRAVE INJURY TO MY CONSTITUENTS --
LOOK TO THIS BUILDING NEEDS
UPGRADES THE AT THE ANNEX NEEDS
UPGRADES BUT WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN UPGRADE
THE EXISTING BUILDING --
FOR A FAR CHEAPER PRICE --
LOOK MEMBERS IS PRICES SIMPLY
JUST TOO HIGH AND IT AND FRANKLY
I THINK IT SENDS THE WRONG
MESSAGE IF THERE'S IF THERE'S
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN THE
BUDGET.
OFFER OTHER FOR OUR PROJECTS IF
THERE'S BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
WE WANT TO BE SPENDING IT LET'S
LOOK AT THE PROJECTS THAT SHOULD
BE SHOULD BE SPENDING WE SHOULD
BE SPENDING IT ON OURSELVES A
NEW SWANKY OFFICES.
THIS LEGISLATURE TOLD THE FOSTER
YOUTH IN MY DISTRICT AS THEY DID
EARLIER THIS YEAR THE SIX
MILLION DOLLARS FOR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS IN RICHMOND ACTIVITIES
WAS TOO MUCH.
AND I HAVE TO QUESTION HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
POLITICIANS OFFICES WHEN THIS
LEGISLATURE SAYS THAT AT RISK
YOUTH IN MY DISTRICT OTHERS.
AS THEY DID EARLIER THIS YEAR
THAT FEEDER PROGRAMS TO LEARN
CONSTRUCTION SKILLS OR CARE FOR
THE ELDERLY ARE TOO EXPENSIVE I
HAVE TO QUESTION THE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. FOR SHINY
NEW OFFICES UR POLITICIANS WHEN
THIS LEGISLATURE SAYS IT'S TOO
PRICEY DO ENSURE THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED.
PEOPLE AND THEIR FAMILIES GET
IMMEDIATE SERVICES I WONDER HOW
WE CAN AFFORD A BRAND NEW
CAPITOL BUILDING.
WHEN THIS LEGISLATURE AS IT DID
EARLIER THIS YEAR SAYS THAT
LIMITED TAX CREDITS WOULD ENSURE
FULL EMPLOYMENT AND BETTER WAGES
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT DISABLED IN
MY COMMUNITY?
IS A SO CALLED EXPENDITURE THAT
IS TOO EXPENSIVE TO AFFORD.
I FRANKLY HAVE TO SHAKE MY HEAD
AND WONDER HOW WE CAN AFFORD
SWANKY NEW OFFICES FOR
POLITICIANS MEMBERS ONE POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS FOR NEW
OFFICES FOR US.
WHEN WE ROUTINELY LOOK AT THE
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN WHO I JUST
DESCRIBED IN THE FACE AND WE SAY
THEIR NEEDS ARE TOO EXPENSIVE IT
MAKES ME WONDER WHERE I
PRIORITIES REALLY LIE?
I APPRECIATE ALL THE HARD WORK
OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE DONE
RESEARCHING OPTIONS UP
PARTICULARLY FROM FROM THE
MEMBER FROM RANCHO CORDOVA I
KNOW THIS IS A PASSION FOR A LOT
OF US IN THIS ROOM.
AND I KNOW THAT A LOT OF THE
VISITORS ARE CONFUSED BY
MULTIPLE FLOORS --
WHEN YOU GET OFF A ONE AND
YOU'RE ON THE ON THE OTHER SIDE
IT'S IT'S ON THE OTHER AYE I'M
STILL A YEAR AND A HALF AND?
I HAVE A LITTLE CHALLENGE WITH
THAT BUT BUT MEMBERS WE SHOULD
BE LOOKING AT WAYS THAT WE CAN
THAT WE CAN DO THE THE JOB
EFFICIENTLY EFFECTIVELY WHILE
WE'RE STILL SAVING MONEY AND I
URGE.
A NO VOTE ON THIS THANK YOU.
MS MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I SO
I'VE HAD LENGTHY CONVERSATIONS
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM RANCHO
CORDOVA CORDOVA ABOUT THIS
PROJECT AND IT IS A GOOD PROJECT
AND I THINK.
THERE'S CERTAINLY AN ARGUMENT TO
BE MADE FOR GOING THROUGH THE
IMPROVEMENTS HOWEVER IT SEEMS IN
THIS STATE THE ONLY WAY THAT YOU
CAN GET SOME SEQUEL EXEMPTIONS
IF YOU'RE BUILDING A STADIUM.
OR I GUESS IF YOU'RE RENOVATING
THE CAPITAL SO WHILE WE HAVE A
HOUSING SHORTAGE WHILE WE HAVE A
HOUSING CRISIS WELL WE HAVE.
PEOPLE WHO ARE HOMELESS WHILE WE
HAVE.
BILL BECAUSE SEQUEL ALLOWS
PEOPLE TO GO IN AND SHUT THE
PROJECT DOWN ALMOST FROM THE
FIRST DAY THEY ANNOUNCE IT.
THE LEGISLATURE IS GOING TO
EXEMPT ITSELF FROM THE SAME LIES
THAT ARE SHUTTING DOWN PROJECTS
IN COMMUNITIES WHERE PEOPLE
DESPERATELY IN SORELY NEED THEM.
UP FOR THOSE REASONS I WOULD
URGE A NO VOTE.
MR MATHIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ON THIS RISE IN OPPOSITION THIS
MEASURE WHITE TYPICALLY
SUPPORTER SEQUEL EXEMPTIONS AND
STREAMLINES.
I CANNOT SUPPORT THIS SPECIFIC
EXEMPTION [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
OUR STATE INFRASTRUCTURE IS
CRUMBLING.
WE WE DON'T HAVE WATER.
OUR ROADS OUR GARBAGE.
AND QUITE FRANKLY AND THAT THE
FOLKS IN MY DISTRICT LIVE IN
THIRD WORLD CONDITIONS.
WELL YEAH WE HAVE A BUDGET
[inaudible]
TRAILER BILL.
IT'S GONNA BILL A SHINY NEW
CAPITAL FOR OFFICE.
WHY YET MY PEOPLE STRUGGLE?
WE HAVE WATER STORAGE WE MUST
BUILD.
WE HAVE DANCE THAT NEED TO GET
BUILT.
WE HAVE CONVEYANCE AND THE NEED
TO GET FIX.
WE HAVE POTHOLES THAT NEED TO BE
FILLED.
WE OF HOMES THAT NEED TO BE
BILLS [inaudible]
BUT YEAH.
WE'RE MORE CONCERNED.
ABOUT OFFICE SPACE.
MEMBERS I LIVED TWO YEARS ON THE
GROUND IN IRAQ.
OUT OF THE BACK OF A MILITARY
VEHICLE.
AND YOU GUYS ARE WORRIED.
ABOUT THE SIZE OF OFFICES.
ABOUT HOW NEW THE OFFICES.
I HAVE FAMILIES IN MY DISTRICT
THAT STILL. TO THIS DAY YEARS
AFTER THE DROUGHT DO NOT HAVE
RUNNING WATER.
CAN WE GET A SEQUEL EXEMPTION
FOR THEM.
CAN WE GET A SEQUEL EXEMPTION TO
BUILD MORE STORAGE.
WOULD BE NICE IF WE COULD WE
HAVE THE POWER TO DO THAT.
BUT HERE WE ARE TODAY.
ANOTHER BUDGET ITEM ANOTHER YEAR
FOR ANOTHER FANCY PROJECT.
THE DOESN'T TRULY HELP.
THE PEOPLE ARE STATE ASK FOR NOW.
MR MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER YOU
KNOW IT'S IT'S KIND OF EASY TO
TO TAKE A SHOT AT THIS --
EXPENDITURE YOU HEAR ABOUT IT
WHEN THE BILL NEW CITY HALLS AND
COUNTY OFFICE ADMINISTRATION IN
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES BUT THEY
ARE WORTHY.
PROJECTS WHEN THEY'RE IN OUR
COMMUTER CROSS CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE THERE ARE THAT THERE THE
PUBLIC'S HOUSE.
AND WE KNOW THIS IS ONE OF THE
MOST VISITED PLACES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE SEE SCHOOL
TRIPS.
WE SEE PEOPLE COMING UP HERE FOR
LOBBY DAY.
AND WHAT THEY DON'T KNOW IS THIS
BUILDING.
IS A DEATH TRAP IT'S A FIRE TRAP
AS OUR COLLEAGUE FROM.
IRAN'S RICARDO THAT HAS OUTLINED
FOR THE PAST FEW MONTHS IT'S
VERY VERY DANGEROUS NOT TO
MENTION.
ATA ISSUES ALLOWING PEOPLE TO
GET AROUND FOR AND HEARING ROOM
TO HEAR ROOM TO VISIT WITH THEIR
LEGISLATORS IT REALLY.
IS A WORTHY PROJECT IT IS BEEN
ON THE BOOKS FOR YEARS.
AND FRANKLY IT'S A GREAT USE OF
ONE TIME MONEY.
BECAUSE LEGISLATIVE DEMOCRATS
ATTEMPTED TO SPEND MORE MONEY IN
THE BUDGET ON ONGOING PROGRAMS
LIKE HIGHER EDUCATION.
EARLY EDUCATION HEALTH CARE.
AND GOVERNOR AND OTHERS IN IN
THE NEGOTIATIONS DECIDED WE
SHOULD SPEND MORE MONEY ON ONE
TIME PURPOSES IN CALIFORNIA AND
THINGS LIKE INFRASTRUCTURE.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE PROJECTS IT
MAKES SENSE THE CALIFORNIA.
GUINNESS THE PUBLIC'S HOUSE IN A
GOOD USE OF ONE TIME MONEY IN
OUR STATE BUDGET ASK YOUR I
DON'T THINK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY MR COOLEY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I'M VERY VERY PLEASED
TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
AND I LOOK AT THIS BILL THROUGH
THE LANDS OF OUR GOVERNOR AND I
SEE IN THIS BILL REALLY A
NARRATIVE ABOUT JERRY BROWN AND
HOW HE IS.
APPROACH THESE PROJECTS ACROSS
HIS CAREER.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE HE
SIGNED A BILL BY A FORMER RULES
CHAIRMAN LEON RALPH.
AND THAT BILL PROVIDED FUNDING
FOR A AS YET TO BE FULLY FLESHED
OUT PROJECT TO REBUILD THE WEST
WING.
AND INCLUDED EXPEDITED
PROCEDURES.
BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T WANT TO DRAG
OUT THIS PROJECT AND THEREBY LET
THE EXPENSE RISE.
SO THIS IS REALLY VINTAGE
GOVERNOR BROWN THAT WE SHOULD
MOVE FOR TO POP A PROJECT OF
FIRST IMPORTS TO THE PUBLIC.
AND DO IT IN AN EXPEDITED WAY.
TO MANAGE THE OVERALL COSTS.
THAT EARLIER PROJECT THE WEST
WING.
EVOKES SIMILAR DEBATE AT THE
TIME IT WAS UNFOLDING.
AND YET IF YOU SEE ANY DAY YOU
GO OUTSIDE THIS BUILDING WHETHER
ON A WEEKDAY OR THE SATURDAYS
AND JUST SIT DOWN AND YOU WATCH
PEOPLE APPROACH IN THIS BUILDING.
WALKING THROUGH THIS BUILDING
THIS PEOPLE'S HOUSE. THIRTY
YEARS LATER CONTINUES TO MOVE
PEOPLE.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN THOSE
THIRTY YEARS HAS THE BUSES OF
TECHNOLOGY?
ALL MANNER OF PEOPLE WHO WOULD
NOT OF BEEN WELCOMED AT ALL OF
THAT ORIGINAL BUILDING HAVE
MOBILITY DAY MOTORIZED
WHEELCHAIRS OTHER SORTS OF
THINGS.
IF THEY COME TO THE PEOPLE'S
HOUSE TODAY THEY HAVE DIFFICULTY
NAVIGATING THE CORRIDORS.
QUARTERS ARE JAMMED UP.
THE BATHROOMS ARE NOT A COMEDY
TO THOSE PEOPLE WHICH IS NOT
RIGHT.
SO THIS PEOPLE'S HOUSE AND THAT
IS WHAT THE BUILDING IS ABOUT
THIS.
SYMBOL ON THE STAIRCASES THAT
HANGS DOWN AS PINEAPPLE WHICH IS
NAY EIGHTEEN SIXTY MESSAGE.
ABOUT WELCOMING PEOPLE.
THIS PROJECT IS ABOUT GETTING
THE PARKING NOW FOR MEET OUR
BUILDING WHERE IS A HAZARD.
OPENING UP THE BUILDING SO THAT
THERE'S ROOM FOR PEOPLE TO PASS
WITHOUT JAM IN THE CORRIDORS.
THERE FACILITIES IT WHETHER YOU
ARE ABLE BODIED SEQUENTIAL SENSE
OR MOBILE BECAUSE OF THE PLACE
OF TECHNOLOGY DO YOU ARE WELCOME
HERE.
TECHNOLOGY THAT SUPPORTS OUR
WORK.
I CAN ASSURE YOU I NEVER WORRIED
ABOUT THE CHARACTER OF MEMBERS
OFFICES.
IT'S HOW PEOPLE CAN IN IRAN AND
IRAQ BUT THIS PROCESS IS PROCESS
OF GOVERNANCE.
THIS DELIBERATE OF DEMOCRACY
THAT IS WHAT THIS BUILDING WILL
SUPPORT.
I AM FRANKLY MORE CONCERN ABOUT-OFFICES WILL OUR STANDING
COMMITTEE STAFF. TO NOT BE A
BLOCK AWAY FROM THEIR CHAIRS BUT
BE BACK AT THE BUILDING WHERE
THEY WILL STRENGTHEN OUR POLICY
PROCESS [inaudible]
SO ARM.
THAT THE FINAL THING I JUST WANT
TO NOTE IS.
SOMETIMES ON THIS FOR WE FEEL
VEXED BY THE GOVERNOR THE
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN VERY STRONG
GOVERNOR [inaudible]
OUTSTANDING GOVERNOR.
WE CAN SUMMARIZE FEEL WE HAVE
CHALLENGES WITH THIS GOVERNOR
[inaudible]
BUT THIS ANNEX PROJECT WAS
STUDIED THE BRICKS AND MORTAR
BUILDING. FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR BRICKS AND
MORTAR BUILDING.
WHEN DID YOU ASKED DOES THEIR
CALCULATION FACTORED IN
FURNISHED SEEMS?
ESCALATING COSTS CONTINUE TO USE
OTHER SORTS OF THINGS THEY GET
UP.
TO SEVEN FIFTY FIVE WHAT'S IN
THIS BILL.
IS CASH MONEY.
WELL WHAT THE BUDGET WE HAVE
CASH MONEY FOR THAT NUMBER.
SEVEN FIFTY FIVE BUT GOVERNOR
BROWN HAS ALSO PROVIDED.
ADDITIONAL BOND FINANCES
STRICTLY AS AN ALTERNATIVE IN
THAT SAME NUMBER AMOUNT IT'S NOT
A BILLION AND A HALF. SEVEN
FIFTY FIVE BUT JERRY BROWN WANTS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS BUILDING
WHICH IS HE IS AUTHORIZED HE IS
PUSH.
WILL BE BUILT WILL BE BUILT
EXPEDITIOUSLY.
AND ALL THE FUNDING WILL BE
THERE ARE NOT CONTINGENT UPON
THE NEXT CHIEF EXECUTIVE
CALIFORNIA.
SO I THINK HE HAS EXTENDED
HIMSELF GREATLY. TO CELEBRATE
OUR ABILITY TO PARTNER WITH THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
DO BILL A WELCOME THE PEOPLE'S
HOUSE [inaudible]
AND AWE [inaudible]
I'M.
HONORED TO STAND IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE.
THANK IMAGE COOLEY MISTER MAYES
EUROPE THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS
I JUST WANTED TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS A MEASURE TODAY.
OF OUR ANNEX IS AN ARCHITECTURAL
EMBARRASSMENT.
AND WE ALL KNOW IT THIS THE
PROJECT DOES NEED TO BE DONE FOR
YEARS WELL I DON'T LIKE THE COST
OF IT.
I'M AND OF COURSE THE SEQUEL
EXEMPTION AND OTHER THINGS IT
HAS TO BE DONE I ALSO WHEN I
THINK OF THE CHAIR OF OF THE
ASSEMBLY RULES COMMITTEE FOR ALL
OF HIS HARD WORK.
HE'S BEEN VERY METHODICAL IN THE
WAY THAT HE'S PUT THIS TOGETHER
AGAIN I URGE A YES VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE.
THANK YOU MISTER MAYES SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE [inaudible]
MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DECIDED THAT ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLE AND TALLY ABOUT
ICE FIFTY FOUR KNOWS TWENTY ONE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE
GOING TO JUMP TO AB.
EIGHTEEN THIRTY ONE A. B..
EIGHTEEN THIRTY ONE WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE.
HARPER READ.
SOME LEGAL EIGHTEEN THIRTY ONE
BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
ACTUALLY THE STATE GOVERNMENT
MAKING A PREPARATION THEREFORE
TO TAKE IT BACK TO ME LEGAL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET.
MISTER CHENEY MEHLMAN.
I THINK MUCH SPEAKER A. B.
EIGHTEEN THIRTY ONE IS OUR
PROPOSITION TWO INFRASTRUCTURE
BILL.
OR IN LAYMAN'S TERMS ARE RAINY
DAY FUND.
WHEN THE RAINY DAY FUND IS FULL
ALL EXTRA REVENUE GHOST
INFRASTRUCTURE THE BILL SETS BUT
MECHANISM TO USE THESE
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDS?
FOR THE FIRST FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN MILLION GOES FOR STATE
BUILDING PROJECTS IN MAINTENANCE.
AFTER THAT HELP THE FUNDS GO TO
RAIL MODERNIZATION PROJECTS
AWARDED BY THE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY.
AND THE OTHER HALF OF FUNDS ARE
DEDICATED TO THE MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING PROGRAM.
THE BILL ALSO MAKES CERTAIN
APPOINTMENTS AT THE PLEASURE OF
THE SPEAKER RATHER THAN A TERM
APPOINTMENT.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
DAVE MUSTAINE MISTER OBERNOLTE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A
PROPOSITION TWO WHICH WAS PASSED
BY THE VOTERS IN.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN SAYS THAT
ONCE THE BUDGET STABILIZATION
ACCOUNT IS FULLY FUNDED THAT
ACCESS FUNDS THAT WOULD HAVE
GONE TO THE BSA ARE INVESTED
INFRASTRUCTURE.
STATE GOVERNMENT CODE DEFINES
INFRASTRUCTURE VERY BROADLY BUT
IT USES SUCH TERMS AS LAND.
HIM ROADWAYS NAM WATER
CONVEYANCE.
THIS BILL DEDICATES THE FIRST
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS OF INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING TO INSTEAD GO TO STATE
BUILDINGS.
I DON'T THINK THAT THERE'S ANY
QUESTION THAT THE VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA DID NOT INTEND FOR
THAT MONEY TO GO TO STATE
BUILDINGS.
THEY INTENDED IT TO BE USED FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE THE BENEFITS ALL
OF THE PEOPLE OF THE CALIFORNIA.
THINGS LIKE AQUEDUCTS THEN ROADS
AND HIGHWAYS AND BRIDGES AND
DAMS.
WE NEED TO BUILD INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT BENEFITS EVERYBODY TOGETHER
NOT JUST STATE EMPLOYEES ARE NOT
OURSELVES I URGE A NO VOTE.
THEY MISTER OBERNOLTE MISTER
MATHIS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN OPPOSITION OF THIS MEASURE.
AS YOU ALL.
ARE AWARE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW.
THESE EXCESS FUNDS ARE DIRECTED
TOWARDS ALL INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS WITH THE BENEFIT THE
STATE AS A WHOLE.
INSTEAD THIS MEASURE SEEKS TO
PRIZE OR PRIORITIZE CERTAIN
PROJECTS [inaudible]
OVER OTHERS.
LIKE CLEAN DRINKING WATER.
WHY CAN APPRECIATE THE NEED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTIONS IN A
STRONGLY OPPOSED DIVERSION OF
MONEY [inaudible]
FIRST DAY.
OWNED RAIL PROJECTS SUCH AS HIGH
SPEED RAIL.
SIMPLY PUT PROPOSITION TWO IF
RESEARCHER FUNDING WAS NOT MEANT
TO BE SPENT ON THIS PROJECT.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT WE ARE.
INDEED.
VIOLATING THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE.
WHO THOUGHT THAT THEY WERE
VOTING? FOR DULLER IS TO GO TO A
MUCH BROADER PACKAGES OF
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WE HAVE WATER QUALITY PROBLEM IN
THIS STATE WE HAVE AN
INFRASTRUCTURE PROBLEM IN THE
STATE.
IN FUNDING PET PROJECTS IS NOT
THE WAY TO MOVE US FORWARD ASK
FOR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MR MATHIS.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION AND CLARK WELL OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
RESERVE ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE THAT ICE
FIFTY TWO KNOWS TWENTY FOUR
SENATE AMENDMENTS.
OUR CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS THIS IS A BE.
EIGHTEEN THIRTY WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE AB
[inaudible]
EIGHTEEN THIRTY CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN THIRTY BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
ACTUALLY THE BUDGET RESERVES
MAKING APPROPRIATION THEREFORE
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET
[inaudible]
MISTER CHANG.
THEY CAN WITH SPEAKER A B.
EIGHTEEN THIRTY CREATES TO
RESERVE FUNDS.
THE FIRST ONE IS A SAFETY NET
RESERVE TO SET AIDE FUNDS IN
GOOD TIMES.
FOR FOR SURE CASE LOW COST
INCREASES ARE THE TWO SUB A
COUNCIL BE CAL WORKS AND MEDI
CAL.
AND THE START WITH THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR BALANCE
THAT THE RESERVE MAKES SENSE
SINCE DURING A BUDGET DEFICIT
YEAR WITH THE ECONOMY IS GOING
DOWN ARE FOR THE OBVIOUSLY THE
MEDI CAL AND CAL WORKS CASELOAD
WILL PROBABLY.
BE GOING UP IN THE TIME WE HAVE
THE LEAST AMOUNT OF MONEY.
A POOREST OF THIS RESERVE
ACCOUNT I'VE MAKES A LOT OF
THINGS DURING THIS TIME.
OUT WE ALSO CREATING A BUDGET
DEFICIT A SAVINGS ACCOUNT WHICH
IS FIRST PROPOSED IN A BILL BY
MY COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY
CERTAIN SUB.
SIX IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
THIS RESERVE REPEAL HOLDEN
ACCOUNT FOR THE ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR DISCRETIONARY
PREDEFINED TRANSFER.
IF THE ACTUAL AMOUNT NEEDED TO
FILL THE BRAIN DEFINED AS ONE
SEVEN BILLION THIS FUND RETAIN
HALF THE BALANCE THE OTHER HALF
GOES TO THE SAFETY NET RESERVE.
FINANCE THE LA ON THE
LEGISLATURE WORK ON THE RULES
FOR THE DEPOSITS AND WITHDRAWALS
FOR BOTH RESERVES.
OVER THE NEXT YEAR WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU TING MEASURE OBERNOLTE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THIS TRAILER BILL CREATES TWO
NEW BUDGET SAVINGS ACCOUNTS.
THE STATE ALREADY HAS TO SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS ONE THE BUDGET SAVINGS
ACCOUNT THE BSA WILL BE FULLY
FUNDED THIS YEAR.
THAT ACCOUNT HAS A MAXIMUM
BALANCE OF 10% OF GENERAL FUND
REVENUES.
THE OTHER ACCOUNT THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE IS A SPECIAL FUND
FOR ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTIES WHICH
DOES NOT HAVE A MAXIMUM CAP.
HOWEVER STATE LAW DOES SAY THAT
WHEN THE BALANCE OF THAT SAVINGS
ACCOUNT EXCEEDS 4% OF GENERAL
FUND REVENUES.
THAT WILL TRIGGER AN AUTOMATIC
ONE QUARTER PERCENT REDUCTION IN
THE STATE SALES TAX RATE.
SO THE ONLY REASON FOR CREATING
NEW TYPES OF RESERVE ACCOUNTS.
IS TO AVOID GIVING THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA A SMALL BREAK ON
THEIR SALES TAX RATE.
I THINK IT'S UNCONSCIONABLE ANY
YEAR THAT WE HAVE A NINE BILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET SURPLUS THAT WERE
SEEKING TO AVOID THE
RESPONSIBILITY.
OF LOWERING THE STATE SALES TAX
RATE.
EVEN A SMALL AMOUNT.
EVEN NO THAT THAT'S NOT WHAT THE
LAW REQUIRES ORIGINAL VOTE.
MISTER DALY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
THIS IS AN IDEA WHOSE TIME HAS
COME.
ADDING THE BUDGET DEFICIT
SAVINGS ACCOUNT TO ARE STATE
BUDGET IS SOUND PUBLIC POLICY I
BELIEVE.
ESTABLISHING THIS ADDITIONAL
RESERVE WILL HELP ENSURE WE ARE
NOT FORCED TO MAKE SEVERE CUTS
TO EDUCATION AND OTHER IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS IF THERE IS AN ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN IN COMING YEARS.
EVERY DOLLAR WE HOLDEN RESERVES
WILL BE PRECIOUS IF AND WHEN
THERE'S A NEED.
I WANNA THANK THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE CHAIRED BY MR TUNING
OUR SPEAKER MISTER RENDON.
AND THE NEW DEMOCRATS WHO WERE
JOINT AUTHORS IN THIS EFFORT I
URGE A YES VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS DALY MR ACOSTA
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
I THINK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER I HAVE TO AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BIG BEAR THERE IS
ONLY ONE REASON TO OPEN A NEW
SAVINGS ACCOUNT.
WITHOUT YOUR YOU YOU KNOW IT
SEEMS TO ME YOUR YOUR SPOUSE ON
THE ACCOUNT THAT SO THEY DON'T
SEE IT THIS IS VERY CLEARLY AN
END RUN AROUND STATE LAW THAT
REQUIRES US TO LOWER INCOME
STATE.
STATE SALES TAXES --
TO OUR CONSTITUENTS IF WE HAVE
THIS KIND OF MONEY IF THE STATE
LAW SAYS WE SHOULD BE REFINING
MONEY BACK OR CBO REDUCING SALES
TAXES ON OUR CONSTITUENTS THAT'S
WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING WE
SHOULD NOT BE OPENING UP.
NEW SAVINGS ACCOUNTS TO SKIRT
THE SKIRT CURRENT STATE LAW I
OPPOSE THIS AND I I MEAN URGENT
NO VOTE.
MISTER GRAYSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND I WOULD LIKE TO
RESPOND SOMEWHAT --
AS FAR AS THE THIS IS NOT THE
REASON WHY WE WOULD OPEN UP LET
ALONE BEING THE ONLY REASON --
BEING THAT IN THE LAST RECESSION
THAT WE JUST ALL INJURED THAT
SHOOK THIS STATE TO ITS CORE AT
ONE POINT IT HAD A FORTY MILLION
DOLLAR DEFICIT.
AND WE'RE NOT EVEN AT A TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR RESERVE WHEN YOU
COMBINE ALL THE COUNTS TOGETHER.
I'M SORRY BILLION SO WE HAD A
FORTY BILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT AND
WE'RE NOT EVEN AT A TWENTY
BILLION DOLLAR RESERVE WHEN YOU
PUT IT ALL TOGETHER.
SO I DO RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB --
AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY BY CREATING
AND FUNDING THE BUDGET DEFICIT
SAVINGS ACCOUNT WE WILL CONTINUE
TO BE FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE AND
PRUDENT WITH OUR CONSTITUENTS
TAX DOLLARS HISTORY ISN'T IT DID
DEMONSTRATED THAT GOOD ECONOMIC
TIMES.
DO NOT LAST FOREVER AND SESSION
IS GOING TO COME WE ALSO KNOW
THAT OUR CURRENT RESERVES ARE
EVEN INSUFFICIENT NOW TO SEE US
THROUGH.
THIS MEASURE PUTS US ON A PATH
TO CONTINUE TO SAVE MONEY SO WE
ARE BETTER ABLE TO WEATHER THE
NEXT DOWNTURN NONE OF US AND I
REPEAT NONE OF US WANT TO REPEAT --
WHAT WAS SO DEVASTATING AND THE
CUTS THE REQUIRED CHOICES
BETWEEN EDUCATION PUBLIC SAFETY
SOCIAL SERVICES AND HEALTHCARE
THIS ACCOUNT WILL HELP US AVOID
HAVING TO MAKE THOSE --
SEVERE CUTS AGAIN AND SO FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THEY WHICH GRAYSON MISS MELENDEZ.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM BIG BEAR
MENTIONED THERE IS NO NEED TO
CREATE THIS FINE WE ALREADY HAVE
SAVINGS ACCOUNT WE HAVE A RAINY
DAY ACCOUNT.
AND WHAT THIS DOES BECAUSE
THERE'S NO CAP.
THAT IS PUT INTO PLACE FOR THESE
FUNDS IT MEANS AT NO TIME IN THE
FUTURE WILL THIS LEGISLATURE
EVER HAVE TO GIVE MONEY BACK TO
THE TAXPAYERS.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO CAP SO WEEK
IS WHAT SAYING YOU KNOW THE
YEARS CONTINUE WHERE WE HAVE.
MORE OF A SURPLUS THAT WE DO
EVEN THIS YEAR.
SOCKET ALL THE WAY INTO ONE OF
THESE FUNDS AND NEVER GIVEN BACK
TO THE TAXPAYERS AND THERE'S
SOMETHING ELSE WE HAVE.
SOME MENTION MADE OF OF PAINFUL
CUTS IN DURING PAINFUL CUTS --
LOOK AT THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
RIGHT NOW WHO ARE MAKING SOME
REAL PAINFUL CUTS IN THEIR
FAMILIES.
THEY'RE HAVING A HARD TIME
PAYING THEIR BILLS AND I THINK
THEY WOULD LOVE. TO HAVE THEIR
GOVERNMENT TO GIVE THEM BACK
SOME OF THE MONEY THAT IS FAIRS
IN THE FIRST PLACE THAT IS WHY
WE HAVE IT IT IS NOT OUR MONEY
IT'S THE TAXPAYERS MONEY.
AND RIGHT NOW IF YOU LOOK AT
WHAT'S GOING ON IN OUR STATE
WE'VE ALREADY TALKED ABOUT THE
HOMELESS ISSUE WE TALKED AD
NAUSEUM.
ABOUT THE HOUSING CRISIS.
ABOUT THE INABILITY FOR PEOPLE
TO FIND A PLACE TO RENT THAT'S
AFFORDABLE.
BUT THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO ASK
THE GOVERNMENT FOR HELP IN
PAYING THEIR ELECTRICITY BILL
BUT THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO APPLY
FOR HELP TO THE GOVERNMENT.
IN ORDER TO PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE.
THE PEOPLE WHO GO TO EVENTS IN
SOME OF YOUR MEMBERS DISTRICTS
IN ORDER TO GET FREE SCHOOL
SUPPLIES FOR THE KIDS BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T AFFORD THEM.
THESE PEOPLE WOULD LOVE AB BIT
OF MONEY.
THAT WE WOULD GIVE BACK TO THEM
BECAUSE IT ACTUALLY BELONGS TO
THEM SO RATHER THAN US SOCKING
IT AWAY FOR FUTURE SO WE DON'T
HAVE TO MAKE PAINFUL CUTS. TO
THE PROGRAMS THAT WE CARE SO
MUCH ABOUT THAT HELPED GET US
REELECTED HOW ABOUT WE NOT DO
THIS AND MAKE IT A AN OPTION FOR
THIS LEGISLATURE TO GIVE THE
MONEY BACK TO THE PEOPLE WHO
DESERVE IT I URGE IN ABOUT.
MISS WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
ARE HARD WORKING CALIFORNIANS
ARE SRUGGLING IN THIS STATE AND
IN MY DISTRICT I KNOW.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE LEAVING AND
THEY'RE GOING TO IDAHO LIMON
ARIZONA THEY'RE GOING TO TEXAS
AND OTHER PLACES ON SOME.
REALLY HOT AND DRY PLACE HIS
THAT I WOULDN'T WANT TO BE GOING
TO JUST TO ESCAPE THE HIGH COST
OF LIVING IN THE STATE.
OF THE FACT THAT WE GOT SUCH A
BIG SURPLUS CLEARLY INDICATES
THAT WE TOOK IN FAR MORE MONEY
THAN WE NEED OR ARE USING.
AND WE WANNA FUND A LITTLE WAY
INTO THESE ACCOUNTS THAT IN A
WAY WHETHER THE INTENT WAS NOT
TO CIRCUMVENT.
ACTUALLY REDUCING THE STATE
SALES TAX BY A QUARTER PERCENT.
AND THAT'S PART OF OUR LAWS SO I
THINK ARE HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIANS ARE BETTER ABLE.
THAN BETTER KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT
HOW TO USE THEIR OWN MONEY AND I
WOULD --
ENCOURAGE SENDING IT BACK TO
THEM RATHER THAN THE STATE
FUNNELING AWAY I URGE IN THE
OVAL.
MR GRAY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THEY MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE. TO RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM BIG BEAR.
AND THE ARGUMENT PUT FORTH --
THAT THERE'S ONLY ONE REASON. TO
INCLUDE THIS ADDITIONAL SAVINGS
ON THE BUDGET.
THERE IS THE NEW DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS PUT FORTH PROPOSALS
CREATE ADDITIONAL SAVINGS
ACCOUNT.
AND THE PURPOSE [inaudible] FOR
THAT WAS IT OVER THE PAST THIRTY
YEARS WE'VE AVERAGED ONE
ECONOMIC RECESSION PER DECADE.
WE HAD A RECESSION THE EARLY
NINETEEN NINETIES WE HAD THE DOT
COM BUST NEARLY TWO THOUSANDS.
MORE RECENTLY WE ALL EXPERIENCE
THE GREAT RECESSION.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THIS BODY
WAS MORE THAN THREE MONTHS LATE
IN DELIVERING A BUDGET TO THE
GOVERNOR BECAUSE OF FUNDING
SHORTFALLS.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE THE STATE
WAS LATE PAYING ITS OWN BILLS
BECAUSE OF A THREE AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLAR CASH FLOW PROBLEM.
THIS DOESN'T INCLUDE DRASTIC
CUTS TO EDUCATION HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND PUBLIC SAFETY.
THE STATE'S NONPARTISAN
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S INDICATED
EARLIER THIS YEAR THAT
CALIFORNIA WOULD NEED A RESERVE.
AND AS MUCH AS TWENTY BILLION TO
PREVENT DRASTIC CUTS DURING A
MILD RECESSION.
AND FORTY BILLION FOR SOMETHING
MORE SEVERE.
THE PROPOSED FULLY FUNDED RAINY
DAY FUND IS JUST OVER HALF OF
WHAT CALIFORNIA WOULD NEED. TO
GET THROUGH A MILD RECESSION.
SO EVEN TODAY MEMBERS WERE NOT
SOLVING THE ENTIRE PROBLEM BUT
THIS PROPOSAL WILL HELP CLOSE
THAT.
SAVINGS GAP.
SO THAT WHEN THE NEXT RECESSION
HIT THOSE OF US SITTING HERE ARE
FORCED CHOOSE BETWEEN GOOD
EDUCATION FOR OUR CHILDREN.
OR OFFERING HEALTH CARE AND
SERVICES TO OUR SENIORS.
IT IS NOT A PERFECT PROPOSAL BUT
IS AN IMPROVEMENT.
I IN IS A GOOD IDEA TO SAVE
MONEY FOR HARD TIMES IF THIS
BODY CAN GET TO A PLACE WHERE WE
CAN DO SIGNIFICANT TAX REFORM.
AND AVOID A CONTINUING BOOM AND
BUST CYCLES THAT WOULD BE A GOOD
THING BUT UNTIL WE'RE THERE A
SAVINGS ACCOUNT MAKES SENSE AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GREAT MR MATHIS
YOU'RE RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
EVERY YEAR THROUGH WE CONTINUE
TO HEAR THIS THREAT THE NEXT
RECESSION IS COMING THE NEXT
RECESSION IS COMING.
THE NEXT RECESSION IS COMING.
HOW WE MANAGE OUR STATE BETTER
AND STOP THREATENING OUR PEOPLE
WITH THE RECESSION?
HOW ABOUT THAT?
HOW ABOUT INSTEAD OF TELLING
HOME HEY LET'S CREATE A NEW
ACCOUNT?
THAT WE DON'T NEED AND HIDE THE
MONEY AWAY FROM THEM.
LET'S GIVE HIM A CUT.
WAS GONNA BREAK.
AND SO TO COME UP WITH SOMETHING
NEW AND THREATENING THEM EVERY
SINGLE TIME THERE'S A RECESSION
COMMON.
WE OUGHT TO OWN UP TO OUR
RESPONSIBILITY IN TO THE OATH WE
TOOK IS LEGISLATURE'S AND MANAGE
THE STATE BETTER OR TO ENSURE A
BETTER FUTURE.
INSTEAD OF THREATENING THEM IN
MAKING UP THIS CRAZY LAND OF ALL
THOSE FAKE ACCOUNTS. TO HIDE
MONEY AWAY FOR FUTURE RECESSION
THAT WE WOULD ACTUALLY DO OUR
JOBS WE WOULDN'T BE THREATENING
EVERY TIME ASK FOR NO VOTE.
MISS CABALLERO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS -- I
WAS HERE.
WHEN WE HAD TO MAKE THOSE UGLY
CUTS?
I REMEMBER WHAT IT FELT LIKE.
AND IT'S INTERESTING TO MEET TO
BE STANDING HERE TODAY.
AND TO BE ARGUING OVER SAVING
MONEY.
I JUST SAY IT'S REALLY BIZARRE
TO ME.
BECAUSE IF YOU REALLY LOOK AT IT
THERE'S NOTHING SECRET.
ABOUT THIS ACCOUNT WHICH IS
CREATING ANOTHER ACCOUNT AND AND
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH.
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST WHO WE
ALL TRUST AND BELIEVE AS A
NEUTRAL.
A OBSERVER OF THE BUDGET.
AND WHO GIVES US RECOMMENDATIONS
ALL THE TIME PREPARED A REPORT
CALLED BUILDING RESERVES TO
PREPARE FOR A RECESSION.
BECAUSE WE KNOW.
THAT A RECESSION COMES ON A
REGULAR BASIS.
AND SO PART OF WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE WITH THIS BILL.
IS LOOKING TO CREATE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SAVE AS MUCH
MONEY AS POSSIBLE.
I WANT TO SAY THAT AGAIN TO SAVE
AS MUCH MONEY AND AS POSSIBLE.
AND WHAT THEY PREDICT
[inaudible]
IN THIS DOCUMENT AGAIN A NEUTRAL
DOCUMENT IS THAT WE'RE GONNA
NEED BETWEEN. FIFTEEN TO THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS.
BETWEEN A MILD OR MODERATE
RECESSION THE LAST RECESSION WE
HAD.
WAS NOT MILD OR MODERATE.
IT WAS EXTREMELY SEVERE WE HAD
NOT SEEN A DOWNTURN.
IN OUR ECONOMY SINCE THE GREAT
DEPRESSION IN CALIFORNIA AND SO.
MEMBERS THIS IS A PRUDENT
APPROACH HE PROVIDES US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PUT MONEY ASIDE.
AND IN THE EVENT THAT WE HAVE AN
UNUSUAL OCCURRENCE I COULD TELL
YOU LAST YEAR.
THAT ARE NATURAL DISASTERS
CREATED A WHOLE BUNCH OF UNUSUAL
OCCURRENCES BETWEEN FIRES AND
LANDSLIDES AND FLOODS.
WE ARE GOING TO NEED MONEY IN
RESERVE.
AND SO THIS IS A PRUDENT
APPROACH AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY WAS CABALLERO MISTER
PATTERSON YOU ARE THANK THANK ME
SPEAKER OUT MEMBERS [inaudible]
I'M.
LOOK WHAT IS IRRESPONSIBLE.
IS TO RATCHET UP SPENDING AS
DRAMATICALLY AS THIS BODY IS
DONE.
AS THOUGH IT LOS ANGELES TIMES
COLUMNIST THAT MISTER SKELTON
BRO NOT.
JUST A FEW DAYS AGO.
THIS IS AN ON PRESIDENT ID
EXPLOSION.
IN THE SPENDING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO TWO HUNDRED AND
SOME TO NEARLY TWO HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS.
WE SET UP A HUGE [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
SPENDING.
AND THEN SAY MY GOODNESS.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO REDUCE
SOME OF THAT SPENDING IN.
TOUGH YEARS.
SO THE BAIT AND SWITCH HERE IS.
TO RATCHET UP THE SPENDING AND
THEN SAY WE'VE GOT TO HANG ON TO
THE TAXPAYER MONEY.
IN ORDER TO MAKE ALL OF THAT BIG
SPENDING [inaudible]
AW [inaudible]
PALATABLE.
DIDN'T IS THIS NOT SELF EVIDENT
TO THIS BODY.
I THINK THAT IT IS.
AND AS A RESULT OF IT BEING SELF
EVIDENT THE ONLY CONCLUSION WE
CAN COME.
TO IS THAT THERE'S MAJORITY.
THERE'S GOING TO SEAL IN THE
PERMANENCY.
THIS RECORD HIGH SPENDING.
AND THEN SUGGEST THAT THE
TAXPAYERS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
CANNOT GET BACK ANY OF THEIR TAX
MONEY AS A RESULT [inaudible]
SECONDLY.
WHERE DOING A HORRIBLE INJUSTICE
TO THE WHOLE NOTION OF WHAT THE
VOTERS GO TO THE BALLOT BOX TO
VOTE ON WHAT PREVIOUS?
UP LAWS HAVE BEEN PASSED.
IN OTHER WORDS TO DO THIS BAIT
AND SWITCH.
WE'RE GOING TO END UP
[inaudible]
DECIDING THAT.
WHAT PREVIOUS LAW REQUIRED THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO DO?
WHICH WAS WHEN YOU HAVE SURPLUS
IT GOES BACK TO THE TAXPAYERS.
WE'RE GONNA CREATE ESSENTIALLY
LAWS THAT BASICALLY SAY THOSE
LAWS DON'T MATTER.
ANYMORE.
SO I WOULD JUST POINT OUT AGAIN
THAT IF YOU RATCHET THE CEILING
SO HIGH.
WE WILL NEVER COME TO A PLACE.
IN WHICH PRUDENT RESPONSIBLE.
DECISIONS MADE WITH RESPECT TO
TAXPAYER MONEY.
YOU ONE A BLANK CHECK FOR THE
FUTURE THAT'S WHAT THIS IS.
AND WE NEED TO BE WILLING AND
CAPABLE OF RECOGNIZING THAT
MANAGING.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IS OUR FIRST
AND FOREMOST RESPONSIBILITY NOT
SIMPLY BLOWING THROUGH EVERY
EXPENDITURE HISTORY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
GROWTH IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T GET ANYWHERE
NEAR. TO THE NEARLY TWO HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS SPENDING THIS
YEAR.
SO WHILE THE WHILE THE GETTING
IS GOOD.
THIS BODY RATCHET SET UP. TWO
UNPRECEDENTED HEIGHTS.
AMEND THEM SAYS.
LET'S SAY FOR THAT RAINY DAY
WHEN ALL OF THIS EXTRA EXCESSIVE
EXPENDITURES.
ARE.
OUGHT TO OF A NATURAL COURSE BE
MANAGED THROUGH.
PRECISION AND PAYING ATTENTION
TO DETAIL IN MAKING SURE THAT WE
STORED THE TAXPAYER MONEY WISELY
I URGE A NO VOTE ON THIS BECAUSE
IT IS SELF EVIDENT WHAT IS GOING
ON HERE.
AND I THINK WE'RE BASICALLY
CREATING AN UNSUSTAINABLE.
THOUGHT PATHWAY OF SPENDING AND
THEN TRYING TO USE THE NOTION OF
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS TO SOMEHOW.
GOT BACK FILL THE HORRIBLE AND
EXPENSIVE DECISIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN SO OFTEN TIME REACHED.
AND THIS BUILDING I URGE A NO
VOTE.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I WOULD NORMALLY SPEAK ON A
BUDGET TRAILER BILL BUT I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT POINT
SOMETHING.
VERY OBVIOUS OUT.
IS THAT NONE OF US SITTING ON
THIS FLOOR TODAY WORK HERE
HAVING TO MAKE THE DECISION TO
MAKE THE CUTS THAT THE PREVIOUS
GENERATION OF LEGISLATORS WHO
SERVED IN THIS BODY HAD TO MAKE.
WE MAY KNOW SOMEONE I KNOW
SOMEONE SOMEONE WHO SAT RIGHT
HERE AT THIS DESK IN THE SAME
POSITION THAT I AM IN TODAY.
MY FATHER WHO HAD TO VOTE TO CUT.
PROGRAMS HE FOUGHT FOR DECADES
TO CREATE TO FIND ALL WHILE MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE OPPOSITE SIDE
OF THE AISLE FROM THE OTHER
PARTY SENSE THAT HOW COULD YOU
DO THIS.
HOW COULD YOU CUT THESE
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS AND ALL THIS
MONEY IN ALL THIS FUNDING FOR
POOR PEOPLE FOR PEOPLE THAT
CAN'T SUPPORT THEMSELVES HOW
DARE YOU BECAUSE IT WAS ALL
ABOUT POLITICS A WASN'T ABOUT
REALITY?%
AND THIS IS WHAT WE'RE DOING TO
PREPARE OURSELVES FOR THE FUTURE
BECAUSE A RECESSION IS AN
INEVITABILITY IT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN AND WE HAVE TO BE
PREPARED FOR THAT AND THAT MEANS
MAKING THE RIGHT CHOICES.
AT THE RIGHTTIME AND THIS BILL
IS THE RIGHT CHOICE THE RIGHT
DECISION AT THE RIGHT TIME I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THEY CALDERON MISTER DALLI.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I I'M ONE OF THOSE WHO
DON'T SPEAK VERY OFTEN.
BUT THIS DEBATE IS GONE IN A
DIRECTION THAT I DON'T THINK
IT'S VERY HELPFUL.
I GOT ELECTED IN TWO THOUSAND
AND TWELVE WHEN I CAME HERE.
LAST JANUARY HOUSE MY OFFICE HOW
MANY BILLS HAVE BEEN SIGNED INTO
LAW.
THAT'S I CAME INTO OFFICE IN
JANUARY IT WAS. TWO THOUSAND
FIVE WHO ARE 200-070-02200
SEVENTY SIX BILLS HAVE BEEN
PASSED IN THE HAD BEEN SIGNED
INTO LAW FROM THE DAY I CAME ON
THIS FLOOR.
AND I WILL TELL YOU NOT.
ONE NO ONE SINGLE BILLS HELP ME
STAY IN BUSINESS.
NOW I CAN TELL YOU ABOUT TEN
BILLS.
HAVE REALLY DESTROYED.
MY FAMILY FARM BUSINESS THAT I
TRY TO RUN UNEMPLOYED PEOPLE.
I HAVE A TRUCKING BUSINESS I PAY
A HEAVY WEIGHT USE TAX.
NOW TAXES OPPOSED TO GO TO FIX
ROADS YOU KNOW WHERE IT GOES.
HE GOES THE GENERAL FUNDS
BIGELOW THE GENERAL FUND FOR
ABOUT TEN YEARS.
A BILLION DOLLARS HERE THAT WERE
SUPPOSED TO GO TO ROADS GOES THE
GENERAL FUND PER OTHER PROGRAMS.
IT WAS TAKING DURING THE TIME.
THAT MY COLLEAGUE JUST TALKED
ABOUT WHEN THERE WAS NEEDED CUTS
TO TAKE CARE OF OTHER PROGRAMS.
BUT WE HAVE AN EXCESS BUDGET DO
WE GO BACK TO TAKE THAT MONEY
AND PUT IT TO ROADS NO WE DON'T.
WE CONTINUE TO PUT IT INTO THE
GENERAL FUND WE DON'T TAKE CARE
OF ALL THE CASES THAT WE WERE.
SENT HERE TO TAKE CARE OF AND
HERE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT.
EXTRA REVENUE WE TRADE A SPECIAL
BOND SO WE DON'T HAVE TO GIVE IT
BACK TO THE PEOPLE WHO EARNED IT.
AND PIMP AND PAY IT THAT'S
PEOPLE LIKE ME IN MY BUSINESS.
I WAS SURE WINNER THAT THING
WITH YOU. FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
TWENTY PLUS YEARS.
I'VE BEEN RUNNING MY SEED
BUSINESS THE PEOPLE FROM OREGON
SHIP PRODUCTS TO MY CUSTOMERS.
I SOLD THEM PER PRICE THAT'S I
COULDN'T COMPETE WITH.
I THOUGHT THEY WERE JUST TRYING
TO DRIVE THE PRICE DOWN THEY
ACTUALLY SHOWED ME THEIR BIDS
OUT TO BID ON THESE PRODUCTS.
SAME EXACT VARIETY.
AND I CAN'T COMPETE NAMA TELL
YOU SOMETHING.
WHEN I CAN'T RUN MY FARM AND I'M
NOT HERE ANYMORE I'M NOT PAYING
TAXES?
AND NOBODY CAN RUN UP FARM LIKE
I RUN I'M CRAZY ENOUGH TO WORK.
TWENTY HOURS A DAY TO KEEP THAT
FAMILY FARM RUN.
AND THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
BUSINESSES ARE IN THE SAME PLACE
I AM IN.
LET'S SKILLED BUILD SOME TRUST
BACK TO THE PEOPLE WHO PAY THE
BILL.
IF WE'RE GONNA REYES ATTACKS ON
A GIVEN THE MONEY BACK WHEN IT'S
WHEN WE TAKE CARE THE
OBLIGATIONS AND WE'RE NOT DOING
THAT.
THIS BILL IS HIDING MONEY SO WE
DON'T HAVE TO GET BACK.
THAT TAX BREAK TO PEOPLE WHO PAY
THE TAXES IT'S WRONG.
VOTE NO ON THIS GIVE THE MONEY
BACK TO THE PEOPLE PAY THE BILL
BUILD SOME TRUST AND MAYBE
SOMEDAY YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA I'M
TELLING YOU WHEN YOU SEE A DIP
DOWNTURN YOU CAN'T COME GETTING
MORE FOR ME BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE
ANYMORE.
AND IT'S COMIN.
BEEN REGULATED TO DEATH BEEN
TAXED TO DEATH.
AND YOU NO MY ROAD STILL ROUTE
EVEN THOUGH IT PAID TO MAKE
THINGS MOVE [inaudible]
IT'S WRONG.
AND THEN YOU KNOW WHAT THE
CHICKENS ARE GOING TO COME HOME
TO ROOST SOON.
AND IT'LL BE REALLY TOUGH WOMEN
THEY CAN REALLY TOUGH DECISIONS
WE'VE ALREADY OVERTAXED
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA.
URGING NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MITCH DOWLING MISTER
TANG.
BUT WHICH YOU MAKERS.
I THINK IT'S QUITE INTERESTING
OFTENTIMES IN GOVERNMENT WE'RE
TOLD TO RUN.
MUCH MORE LIKE A BUSINESS.
AND IF YOU EVER HAVE.
A FAIR.
IN YOUR DISTRICT TALK ABOUT
CONSUMERS AND TELLING.
PEOPLE HOW BEST TO BE FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE WAS.
WHAT'S THE ONE THING YOU TELL
THEM TO DO [inaudible]
SAVE MONEY.
YOU WOULD NEVER TELL A
CONSTITUENT DON'T SAVE MONEY.
DON'T OPEN A SAVINGS ACCOUNT TO
GO TO THE BANK.
SPEND AT ALL IF YOU HAVE EXTRA
[inaudible]
GUESS WHAT [inaudible]
GIVEN BACK.
WE'VE BEEN TOLD THE GOVERNMENT
SHOULD RUN MORE LIKE A BUSINESS.
WELL IF YOU LOOK AT GOVERNMENT'S
BALANCE SHEET.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE BALLOT SHEET
OF GOVERNMENT [inaudible]
IT STICKS.
BECAUSE WE DON'T SAVE ANY MONEY
WHEN WE HAVE A RAINY DAY.
SO I THINK IT'S VERY HARD TODAY
THAT WE HAVE A DEBATE ABOUT
RUNNING THIS MORE LIKE A
BUSINESS.
WHICH IS WHAT YOU WOULD LOOK AT
A WALL STREET YOU LOOK AT THE
BALLOT SHEET OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
IS WHY ARE BOND RATINGS ARE
GOING BACK UP.
BECAUSE WERE BEING FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE WE ARE SAVING MORE
MONEY WERE ACTING MORE LIKE A
BUSINESS [inaudible]
YEAH THE PEOPLE WHO EXACTLY
ADVOCATE THAT ALL THE ONES
ARGUED AGAINST IT.
TODAY WE'RE SEEING THE
CALIFORNIA'S WE'VE HEARD YOU WE
ARE BEING FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE
WE ARE ACTING LIKE A BUSINESS
WE'RE SAVING MONEY SO WHEN THE
RAINY DAY COMES.
WE CAN OPEN THAT UMBRELLA IN
MAKE SURE YOU DON'T GET WET WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK DRIVER.
DANISH CHIANG AND WITHOUT CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
THIS I TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ALL.
AND TALLY THE VOTE EYES.
FIFTY FOUR THERE'S TWENTY ONE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
MEMBERS NEXT IS A. B.. EIGHTEEN
THIRTY FOR WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN THIRTY
FOUR BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND ACTUALLY TO CORRECTIONS
MAKING A PREPARATION THEREFORE
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET.
MISTER CHANG EMAIL.
THANK YOU AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY
FOUR INCREASES THE CDC ARE BOND
AUTHORITY BY FORTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE HEALTH CARE.
STILL BE IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS
BRINGING THE TOTAL PROVIDER FOR
THESE PROJECTS TO ONE POINT. OH
NINE BILLION CDC ARE USES THIS
BOND AUTHORITY ONLY FOR HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES CONSTRUCTION
IMPROVEMENTS.
MANY OF WHICH ARE DICTATED BY
THE FEDERAL RECEIVER WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THEY RETAIN MISTER OBERNOLTE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST LOOKED INTO
THIS ISSUE AND ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PROVIDE SOME
JUSTIFICATION AS TO WHY CDC ARE.
NEEDED INCREASED BORROWING
AUTHORITY FOR THESE PER ALTHOUGH
THE ADMINISTRATION IDENTIFIED
THE FOURTEEN PROJECTS THAT THE
MONEY WOULD BE SPENT ON THEY
WERE UNABLE TO PROVIDE A
JUSTIFICATION.
AS TO WHY THE MONEY WAS NEEDED
OR WHATEXACTLY IT WOULD BE
SPENT ON IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
APPROVE THIS INCREASE IN
BORROWING AUTHORITY WITHOUT THAT
JUSTIFICATION I URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE OF IT I
SHOULD THREE NO'S TWENTY TO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL.
ON S. B..
EIGHT FORTY THIS IS THE
CONFERENCE REPORT.
CLARK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS HER WISH TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE.
THIS IS THE CONFERENCE REPORT
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TELL YOU
ABOUT AYE AYES FIFTY SEVEN KNOWS
TWENTY THREE THE CONFERENCE
REPORT IS ADOPTED [inaudible]
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED MEMBERS --
JUST. FOR A BRIEF MOMENT A I
WANT TO LET EVERYBODY KNOW.
THAT TOMORROW IS THE BIRTHDAY OF
OUR PRESIDING OFFICER MISTER
MOMENTS OF YOU COULD JOIN ME IN.
CONGRATULATING HIM ON HIS
BIRTHDAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON LET ME
RESPOND BY SAYING WE STILL THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
VISITING MEMBER WAS REMOVED AND
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR SEEING
AND HEARING ON THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SEC CALENDAR ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TWO ONE TWO BY SOME
MEMBER KILEY AND OTHERS MELTED
AT THE W. SHARECROPPER BOBBY
FRENCH MORAL HIGHWAY.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS
VOTER WISHED ABOUT THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR MEMBERS ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS IS CONSENT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE OR DESIRE TO
VOTE THIS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE I SEVENTY SIX KNOWS.
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CAN.
HONOR ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TO TWENTY AYE SEVENTY
SIX KNOWS HEROES ON THE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TO TWENTY
FOUR BY SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO THIRTY AYE SEVENTY SIX KNOWS
HERE ON THE COMPARISON TO THIRTY
SIX I SEVENTY SIX NOCERA SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
ONE FORTY FOUR BY SEVENTY SIX NO
ZERO SENATE BILL FIFTEEN OUT TO
I SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
BILL NINE OH THREE WITH URGENT.
I SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY I SEVENTY SIX KNOWS ARE
ON THE BILL AND SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY
EIGHT I SEVENTY SIX KNOWS.
ZERO MEMBERS TE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
FRIDAY JUNE FIFTEENTH NO FLOOR
SESSION NO CHECK IN SESSION
MONDAY JUNE EIGHTEENTH.
FLOOR SESSION IS A ONE PM ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WOULD PASS
RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER TANG MOVES AND DOCTOR
WOULD SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
JUNE EIGHTEENTH AT ONE PM.
AND A QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED
.
WHAT CHANGES STEVEN CHOI SP --
A FIFTY TWO TO KNOW TO AYE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI.
SENATE BILL EIGHT EIGHTY TWO
NOTES I CORRECTION.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI
SENATE BILL EIGHT FIFTY TWO
NOTES I ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA -- AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SIX ITEM.
THOUGH CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK SILVA AS LEGAL EIGHTEEN
TWENTY SIX ICE NO